[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the mlb game of the week free
game show presented by chime guess who's
on the mound tonight guess who's in the
lineup tonight
that guy
that is if there was ever like the dual
threat
that's you're looking at right there
number 17. he is in the two spot tonight
in the lineup for the angels oh and
he'll be on the mound and he's a
strikeout machine and he goes for an
angels team that's looking to wipe away
a three-game losing skid they face off
against the detroit tigers and on the
other side of the pitching pairing is
matt manning who makes his mlb debut
this is a big deal prospect six foot six
he's about your height and he's got big
time stuff and he can get up near triple
digits 2019 he had a big year in double
a ball there were some people in the
tigers organization that thought stuff
wise he might be their best prospect
coming up in the minor leagues even
better than casey
that's saying a lot but you're going to
get a look at it tonight big big
fastball 98 he'll hit triple digits on
occasion too dan please sack by the way
scott braun we're with you for the next
30 minutes and then we'll get you to
first pitch with ohtani on the mound in
this one okay let's recap on how these
two teams did yesterday
willy castro stands in with a runner on
first and nobody down
a drive to right center field that
ball's deep that ball is gone away
willie willie castro with a two-run shot
to tie it up at three
oh
and it gets by gallagher and grossman's
gonna score the tigers take the lead
there he goes here's the o2 swung out of
this boy michael and he strikes out
perez on three pitches to end it
and here's pinder hinder hitting for
brown
and that's a line drive base in left
field
lowry's being waved home lowry's gonna
score and this game is tied at four so
the bases will be loaded with nobody out
kemp
shallow center a thing of beauty
chapman comes in to score and the a's
lead 5-4
he's looking for some contact here which
would likely give the is their seventh
run
fletcher's coming home the throw is high
everybody's safe anders scores and it's
7-4
all right the a's are really good they
swept the angels tigers swept the royals
and this is their starting lineup
tonight robbie grossman on baseman their
best hitter recently has been jonathan
scope starting to have flashbacks to
those years when he's hitting bombs with
manny machado in baltimore that's right
he was second baseman back then he's
doing a lot of first space in dh these
days miggy's in there eric haas has been
a big story for the tigers first few
weeks the story for the tigers was akiel
badu you might know the last name of the
center fielder in the nine spot that's
daz cameron and he is the son of mike
cameron young prospect with the tigers
on the angels side their starting lineup
features justin upton at the top offense
has been cranking more with jeff in the
laid off spot that's a very joe madden
move unconventional guy at the top of
the order you normally think of him as a
three four five hole hitter but a lot of
teams have gone to that cubs did that
with anthony rizzo put him at the top
maybe get a few more heaters and it's
worked shohei ohtani is pitching tonight
there's no dh this isn't american league
park but they go with ohtani in the
lineup of course makes sense he's also
the leading candidate for dh to
represent the american league at the
all-star game more on that a little bit
later but also shohei ohtani is
i would say the most unique player in
major league baseball at this point
hard to comp and i love comping guys to
different guys from different eras i
don't know how to comp this guy because
we've seen nothing like this guy you
know when he came from japan the first
spring training when he was in tempe
he was awful hitting and he was awful
pitching and the word was i don't know
what this guy could do is he even gonna
make the team but you know what but
there's mike trout going down and so
everyone thought the angel season was
going right down the drain right well
guess what happened it's ohtani land i
mean watch where this ball goes this is
like nearly 500 feet this one off of
cole irvin is an absolute missile that's
off a good friend of mine did i know
that was off my nephew zach so what can
he do on the mound
electric he is a ace top rotation 95 to
100. look at this one
101 scott he throws absolute bullets so
then you get up there and you're looking
for that 97 to 100 you're like okay i'm
gonna get this guy he moves the ball in
out up and down and then uh oh the
dreaded equalizer most pictures call
that you know it's the changeup with him
it's the split finger
anywhere from 84 to 90 miles an hour
to go with it has a good slider to go
along with it we've never seen anything
like this guy so he's impossible for me
to comp to because nobody hits like this
guy does what i can't imagine is
how you could even warm up for a game
you're getting your warm ups you're
gonna do what you're gonna do and then
you're also hitting second so what are
you thinking about you think about
pitching you're thinking about hey what
am i gonna do in the bottom of the
inning and so this guy has a lot of
different things going on but i mean you
take a look at that graphic that says it
all right there that screams all-star
and he has to be
what would be the coolest thing ever
would be for him to start the all-star
game on the mound and get in a bet i
think it would be great and i think
that's what a lot of people in baseball
want to see they want to see more of
ohtani we deserve it i think the world
deserves it right now ohtani on the
mound and at the plate and that's a
great point i didn't even think about
that
shohei ohtani at the plate is probably
more worried on a day like today about
how his pitching performance is going so
maybe that helps even i mean there's no
nerves you think about all the things
that could possibly go wrong you fall a
ball off your foot then can you go out
there he's done this before he followed
off a couple of starts ago off of his
knee so then if you're the angels you
have to be careful you don't want to
send him out there to pitch the next
inning if he's favoring that knee and he
hurts his shoulder hurts his elbow
they've used them in the outfield this
guy he's he's an incredible player yeah
and you're going to see him about 20
minutes from now you get the best of
ohtani you got him on the mound you get
them at the plate you'll also get a
great call on youtube coming up when
they get you there for first pitch and
that also includes during the game poll
questions to get you involved i know
you're watching from home on the road
wherever you are you're on your mobile
device and you're going i want to
participate you can that's what
youtube's all about when you're watching
these games exclusively right here
tiger's angels
nice and simple for the pre-game show
who's going to win tonight's game the
tigers with matt manning making his
debut or shohei otani with that shiny
era much more to go on the pre-game show
presented by chime and that includes
ohtani mike trout is going to talk to us
during the game in the third inning
tonight big day on youtube
santana lifts that one left field
justin's got a long way to go still
going
with the catch
[Applause]
over that yellow line
brendon base it left field on a fastball
here comes ohtani ben and he uncorks it
to the plate not in time one to nothing
halo that's another rbi number 600
[Music]
[Applause]
this is what they got they got that
fight
they were up there trying to do as much
damage as they could there's damage
right there
way
way
[Applause]
goodness
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
what's going on that guy's mind right
now right yeah we are presented by chime
i'm scott brun dan plisack with me for
the ride getting you up to first pitch
and
highest contact rate in major league
baseball belongs to if it's current
players active players i should say
david fletcher actually nick magical
unfortunately out for the rest of the
season fletch has been a do-it-all guy
for the angels
and david fletcher of the angels joins
us right now pre-game fletch thanks for
the time looks like terrible weather out
there as usual i know you grew up in the
area do you ever just go outside pregame
take your time look around and go wow i
mean there's never going to be a rain
delay here
yeah we're really lucky here um
always good weather we had one rain
delay i think it was last year the year
before and uh might have been the first
one ever
yeah it's super weird when there's rain
it's very rare we talk about it when we
see it out there because it's just such
a beautiful day just about every day i
know mark gobes that tells us that all
the time you can't beat this job you
grew up in orange county what was it
like playing baseball in the area who
did you watch who did you root for give
us the goods
yeah i mean playing around here i got to
play all year long
with the weather and not a lot of people
get to do that around the country so
i think that that really helped me
growing up and
i mean players i watched growing up
david eckstein
pedroia was a big one for me
um really enjoyed the way those guys
played and modeled my game after him
have you ever been able to connect with
any of the two that you just mentioned
yeah luckily for me uh eckstein came to
spring training a few times and
i got to talk to him and pick his brain
so uh that's been uh that's been great
for me to have a be able to have contact
with him how much does it mean to you to
get a comp like david eckstein based on
the fact that i mean he was a contact
gritty gamer do whatever the team needs
i mean how much does it mean to you to
watch him have him be your favorite
player idolize him growing up and then
almost kind of turn into a great version
of him in the major leagues yourself
yeah i mean that's the biggest
compliment i can get is uh
just playing the game the right way like
he did and and
i
mean
kind of not taking anything for granted
and not giving away at bets
i think a lot of people watch you david
and say i want to do what david fletcher
does i want to be the guy that that
makes contact still has a great eye can
play wherever he needs to so let's go go
over exactly the life on game day of
david fletcher so can you take me
through your schedule and let me know if
it's the same thing every day like start
with i wake up
for a game day like today what time
you're getting to the park what specific
things you're doing when are you
potentially looking at video scouting
reports when are you eating give me the
sketch
a pretty simple guy
wake up maybe 10 o'clock sometimes 11
get some breakfast
head to the field
a
game like today get here around
1 32
kind of get the body loose in the weight
room move around a little bit
i have a real simple cage routine get a
couple get a couple flips and uh
go out to bp take some ground balls and
and get some food get ready for the game
what are you eating and drinking on game
day anything specific that you're going
to every single day
uh a lot of water yep
a lot of stuff to hydrate and then uh
maybe whatever they got in the in the
food room and then occasionally a pb j
too perfect and then post game chilling
so everybody does something to unwind to
relax i know you love talking the game
but after you get out of the clubhouse
and you were talking about what just
happened you get home or you get to the
hotel room what's the go-to for david
fletcher to say all right let me wind
down and get some good rest tonight
uh i mean we've been playing a lot of
cards lately and uh
we got some video games on the phone
that we play with uh ohtani and his
translator ipe
other than that just kind of hanging out
and and having fun well you mentioned
otani take me inside the life of shohei
everybody wants to know what he's like
so let's do it this way what's it like
playing video games against him is he
super competitive and can he can he do
everything can he do more than everyone
else like does he play as two players at
once
yeah he's really competitive um
he's good at he's good at almost
everything he does so
it's fun to compete with him and uh
he's pretty much the same guy all the
time so
it's fun to be around tell me about how
the team is looking right now if you
could evaluate the angels at their
current status and the way that they've
been playing especially over the past 10
days or so what's it looking like
yeah i mean we've been playing good uh
we're a little banged up with trout
trout out obviously and rendon's been
banged up a little bit all year but um
seems like we're coming together and uh
last couple weeks have been definitely
trending upward you're facing matt
manning tonight for the tigers he went
to loyola marymount which or no he
didn't go there sorry you went there
he thought about going there instead
said i'm gonna get drafted if he went
there he was going to play basketball
and baseball so he missed out so what
did he miss out on at school
yeah i had a great time i i was there
for two years at lmu and
a lot of good experiences and and good
development for me as a baseball player
uh but i remember hearing of
manning when he was gonna gonna go there
i think i was gone already but
um heard a lot of good things about him
so excited to face him tonight yeah big
athletic kid and let's finish with this
i think kids watching on youtube would
really appreciate this being that you do
something that almost no other big
leaguer can do as well as you there's
some other names that come to mind of
course like a michael brantley and adam
frazier but the way that you actually
make contact the bat to ball skills how
can you improve that for kids watching
at home how can they get better at
making contact
for me it's a lot of hand-eye
coordination and um
i mean just just hitting a lot and
playing pepper and uh hitting off a
machine
and then having a short swing also helps
and uh being able to get to get the
barrel of the ball david thanks so much
for the time always great to chat good
luck tonight all right
yep thank you i appreciate it
let's check out the latest google
all-star ballot update for designated
hitters in the american league and look
who is leading the pack people want to
see show a he is like the modern day
babe ruth but he throws harder and i
think he hits the ball further exit
velocity proves that although we didn't
have it for bay back then but shohei
leading the vote in dh and you can fill
out your 2021 google mlb all-star ballot
now at mlb.com vote and on google by
searching for your favorite player or
mlb vote shohei ohtani has a chance at
the all-star game if he wants to to be
in the home run derby to be the dh and
maybe throw an inning as well and even
more importantly his manager joe madden
he welcomed all of those things he
thinks it would be great for baseball to
see a pitch in the game and also hit the
game if you had that chance i know you
would take it
i think the coolest thing would be to
start him on the mound get him an inning
let him throw that 98 to 100 that nasty
split and let him get an a b in the
bottom of the inning that's good you
know when you're coming into the game
yes begin this thing and go take it from
the angels enough head time say hey
listen we're going to throw them in
inning yep and we're going to also let
them have an a b and maybe the home run
derby 2 the day before maybe okay so
again 2021 google mlb all-star ballot
right now you can fill it out just go to
mlb.com vote and on google by searching
for your favorite player or go to mlb
vote on google
and time for the creator spotlight
[Music]
dan loves that music i do it's like
smooch
jazz just like austin klechka on youtube
186
000 subscribers he loves the angels he
loves baseball he's been part of dodger
films that youtube channel is amazing as
well and he joins us he is our creator
spotlight right now austin great to talk
to you in person as i always feel like
i'm chatting you with you in the live
chat mentioning you when i'm doing the
play-by-play for games so great to have
you here and also i appreciate you
always chiming in with some great
comments and questions how are you today
i'm doing great feels great to be here
well also let's get you to chime in on
what we just talked about with the
all-star ballot would you like to see
your guy shohei ohtani do everything
that we just mentioned
i want to see him do it all i want to
see him in the all-star game the home
run derby in colorado
he's got to do it that'd be insane
austin has he lived up to expectations
to what you and most angel fans thought
he was going to be when he came over
from japan
[Applause]
i would say he's exceeded especially
this season let's see
and i'd love to see him just ride this
all the way to the end of the season
hey you're a big angels fan and i want
to get to
a big time video that you posted it's
been a minute but it was highly talked
about highly viewed back in the day 2016
you go to an angels tryout take us
through that experience and how you were
able to document it on youtube
so that was actually for a great cause
the angels do it every year around
thanksgiving it's canned food drive you
go there
hands maybe a little bit of money and
you get to take some swings throw some
pitches and you get to have fun on and
you get to feel like a big leaguer i
think that's the coolest part
have to ask you a question you're a
lifelong angels fan
give me your top angels player of all
time
uh i'm gonna say vladimir guerrero yeah
vladimir guerrero i grew up watching him
that's who was the superstar when i got
into baseball and i watched him for a
majority of my life so i'd say vlad
what about a personal favorite mlb
moment either a way that you fell in
love with the game or something that
when i say major league baseball you
think about automatically
for me that would be the no hitter we
threw a couple years ago it was our
first home game after tyler skaggs had
passed and so many people had like other
plans they were inviting me to and i
told them all no like i'm not missing
this game and i'm so glad i didn't miss
that game yeah
that moment unreal and the way the game
turned out
i'm with you that's one we'll never
forget
talking to austin klechka right now our
youtube creator spotlight so
let the world know what your page what
your channel is all about over 57
million views since you joined and
started up your own channel in 2014 give
us the lowdown
i'd say a majority is all about sports
but in the end it's all about having fun
and that's what i just want to portray
in every video and just time right
that's what i want people to come there
for happiness the thrill of the sport
that's what it's all about
is there a secret to how you create so
much interaction and entertainment for
everyone say there's a kid who goes you
know what i want to be like austin i
want to create my own channel i want
people to see what i'm doing and i want
to make people happy what's what's the
key to what you do
uh consistency i would say as long as
you're consistent with it and you got
gotta always thank the fans as well you
gotta remember they're the ones that
make it for you and
yeah that's i would say consistency in
the fans we love that in baseball
consistency we love consistent players
you're definitely a consistent creator i
appreciate you again every single week
on the mlb game of the week and it's
great talking to you now in person
austin and have fun watching this one
with your angels good luck to your squad
tonight okay
thank you hi will go halos
you will see austin in the live chat
talking about this guy his current
favorite player shohei ohtani
get warm we need to see on the mound and
at the plate tonight tigers angels were
close to first pitch
he struck him out save that baseball
that's his first at the major league
level good for jason foley
one away
hannigan drives one to left field but
dude gives chase reaches out and makes
the grab
great closing speed right there for padu
cabrera laces one down the left field
line
that's into the figure
cabrera will dig for second will trot in
there he's got himself a one-out double
his foot 584th
of his major league career deep center
field hill going back and that ball is
caught
he took it off the wall
derrick hill with a spectacular play in
center field
wow
that's right
instead he swings it
deep right field get up it's gone
his first as a major leaguer
ties it
yeah baby
that's worth sticking around for in it
i'm telling you
you gotta say it that's awesome
397 feet
[Music]
the mlb game of the week pregame show is
presented by chime almost time for the
game so it is time for picks to click
presented by fanduel sportsbook okay dan
please sack hanging with us right now
and the first one actually has to do
with our good friend well i wish he was
our good friend shohei ohtani he's busy
he's got so much to do he's hitting he's
pitching so with that being said if he
has an era under three and he hits 30
home runs this year should he win almvp
i'm giving two thumbs up yes what he's
doing we have never seen in the history
of baseball and he's doing both at a
level that i think we are all like in
awe of not only hitting bombs you know
what he's a great base runner and he
runs well
there are a lot of guys around the
angels that think he's their best
athlete and that's saying a lot when you
have a guy like mike trout
this has been an incredible start to the
2021 season and i'm amazed that not only
has he done both but he's done both so
well we're looking at mvp favorites
right now and he's number two i'm gonna
i'm gonna say he might be a slam dunk
now the big key is gonna be for otani
does he wear down by doing both the
second half of the season after the
all-star break if he continues at this
pace he has a legit shot to win that i'm
with you i mean he's such a unique
candidate too the way that he does both
things so well so let's move to the next
one for your picks to click your
favorite to represent the american
league in the world series at this very
moment
right now i'm gonna go a little off the
grid i really like the houston astros i
think you know alex bregman went on the
il they're gonna miss him for a little
bit of time but something tells me i
don't know why the astros they made a
deep run forced game seven with the rays
last year they were one way one win away
from getting to the world series i like
the astros they're my sneaky pick i
think that's a good one you can see plus
700 i mean some people are listening to
you right now going okay
i can do some damage with that
let's see if you stay hot if jacob
degrom is out for an extended period of
time because otherwise if he's pitching
we know he's winning the cy young but if
he's out right and he's had some
injuries some little day-to-day issues
right now who would you pick for n.l
sayon don't laugh it might even be
taiwan walker teammate right now wow he
was so good the other night against the
cubs and he's another guy he spent a
little bit of time on the injured list
he along with marcus stroman give them
the best 1-2-3 combination in the sport
right now i might lean towards taiwan
walker and he's not even on this board
as you can see after degrom there's
woodriff and burns the two brewers
gossman's been nasty with his splitter
if you like splitters the guy that
doesn't get enough credit for having a
monster season zach wheeler down on the
bottom of that graphic godzilla was
really good eight innings of two run
baseball this afternoon for the giants
to pick up his eighth win but boy i'm
gonna tell you what i i don't know why
but i've seen taiwan walker pitch like
three or four times this year and he has
he has found renewed vigor he's pitching
like a different guy yeah he's throwing
harder he's not getting a ton of
attention because he's wearing out
left-handers too yup and wheeler good
call he leads major league baseball in
innings right now he's going deep into
guys we have to start valuing that yes
uh that's a big deal saving the phillies
bullpen giving that team length he's
also first in the national league and
strikeouts his k-rate's up big from last
year okay i got one more test for you
the poll question let's see how everyone
did on youtube and i'll get an answer
from you too dan it looks like angels
fans are weighing in big time tonight
nice and simple and you'll see more poll
questions during the game you'll also
hear from mike trout in the dugout
during the game looking forward to that
but
the
fans have spoken dan and they think the
angels win this one tonight which makes
sense just given the matchup if we're
just looking at pitching alone
you have a guy making his mlb debut
going up against otani who's one of the
best in the biz you have an angels team
that's really scoring well lately and
the tigers are still going through a bit
of a building process they've had some
they've been 20 what is it 20 and 15 in
their last 35 so playing better baseball
in the last month plus but the angels
seem to be the favorite i'm up i'm
following the up to the minute data and
what is that data that's angel's fans
saying probably 80
on all things halos tonight we're with
you okay we believe you it makes sense
there's shohei what do you think is
going through his mind on a daily basis
because there's just so much to prepare
for
think about you when you were coming out
of the game or coming into the game as a
relief pitcher and when you showed up to
the ballpark that night and everything
that you kept in mind on how to keep
yourself fresh and ready for a contest
and then what you double that for show
hey and think about this so he's warming
up right now and he's probably going
through the tigers lineup what he's
going to do the first three possibly or
four or five hitters that he sees a
little game planning then when he's
walking in
he's probably thinking hey i want to see
what this guy has too because he's
hitting second so not only does he have
to worry about what he's going to do the
top of the first inning he's also
worried when he gets to the bottom of
the first he's not like the other guys
most pitchers like what and they sit
down they put a towel across their neck
and they watch he's like he's got to
grab a batting helmet he's going to be
on the on deck circle when this game
starts at the bottom of the first that's
right crazy there's maggie for the
tigers who check in at 29 and 39 on the
year but they've won three in a row also
this is a big deal and i know you love
this
angel stadium tonight
is back to full capacity for the first
time since 2019. hey we've seen some
ballparks lately that went to full
capacity and they call it opening day
2.0 and what the scene is like it's
awesome if you can't be there it's so
fun to watch last friday cubs cardinals
at wrigley field the roof was blown off
of that place even though it doesn't
have one and just think this is so well
timed by the angels pr department second
opening night and ohtani's on the
mountain you can't draw it up any better
than that can you
ohtani and the angels matching up with
the tigers and hey one more quick note i
know i mentioned it earlier but mike
trout is actually going to chat with the
broadcast crew inning in the third
inning derek skubal on the tiger side
but mike trout best player in the game
in the past decade is going to chime in
it's one of the cool features with
youtube not only do we get a player but
we usually get a marquee player most of
the time it's a pitcher that already
pitchers pitching the next day but top
guest for youtube that's as good as it
gets traps on the il that's why he's got
time otherwise you know he'd be playing
but enjoy this one this evening for dan
please sack i'm scott braun thanks for
tuning in to the pregame show presented
by chime it's game time
the history of baseball is so extensive
that players rarely enter uncharted
terrain
yet each game where shohei ohtani both
toes the slab and steps foot in the
batter's box we're left to marvel at the
unprecedented nature of his skills
reaching heights and accomplishing feats
the baseball world hasn't witnessed in a
century ohtani is flourishing in a
fashion that once seemed inconceivable
in the modern game
he's a 21st century high-def two-way
wonder whose value is impossible to
overstate
an all-star caliber starter
one of the most feared sluggers in the
league a six tool player who generates
excitement by breaking the mold
every episode of the ohtani show has the
potential to be history in the making
and tonight man myth and legend collide
in front of a global audience
next on
[Applause]
the
youtube
[Applause]
[Applause]
summer weather has arrived before
summer's actually gotten here in
southern california and from the beach
inland to anaheim stadium
for the showtime show
tonight
welcome to the mlp game of the week live
on youtube presented by chime from angel
stadium a los angeles angels play host
to the detroit tigers
[Music]
one team trying to snap out of a
three-game slide another trying to keep
a three-game winning streak alive with
14-year major league veteran rajay davis
and 14-year major league veteran mark
gubaza matt vasquez great to have you
with us on youtube tonight the only
place you can watch
the shohei show gooby and in this
culture of bigger faster stronger shohei
ohtani checks every box
yeah i mean what he's doing so far this
season i i'm just in total shock every
single night the speed going down the
line you know when you look at it 4.08
seconds going down to first base that's
a list with byron buxton at the top
that's how fast joe hey that stride it's
a smooth easy try down the line whether
he's butting or stealing or just going
down there on a slow hit baseball he is
flying down the line and then you talk
about barrel percentage no one better
not even fernando tatis junior better as
far as the barrel rate by the way hit a
470 foot home run already this season so
the barrel and the distance there for
shohei ohtani and then when he's on the
bump already with 28 pitches at 99 miles
per hour plus already this year jacob
degrom he's in his own world at the top
of that one but also he can dominate
with his fastball he's using a cut
fastball too at the lower third of the
strike zone but he possesses one of the
most unhittable pitches highest k
percent is 67.2 percent with his
splitter 45 strikeouts with a splitter
if he gets ahead 0-1 and go to that
splitter you can almost back on a
strikeout from shohei ohtani on the
mound we'll tip our cap to sonny and
share with the eye gotch u vape
cheekiness but babe ruth had been the
only player in major league history with
a 100 plus rbi campaign and over a
hundred innings of work on the mound and
granted the rbi didn't become an
official stat until after that historic
1919 season but shogeotani is on a pace
for the same kind of workload with way
more homers and with that we say rajay
who's going to face this guy on the
mound for the detroit tigers it's a
rookie right hand or a top prospect matt
manning tonight matt manning he is a guy
that's coming off really his best
outing of his this season this early
season well actually it's kind of
mid-season now so he's actually had
eight strikeouts he's got an explosive
fastball he's gonna have to get ahead of
the hitter so he can get to that
curveball right there because that's
going to be a pitch that is going to be
his pitch to get guys out with yeah matt
manning making his major league debut
tonight as you mentioned had a great
final outing in triple a 9th overall
pick in 2016. he is the number 18
prospect in all of baseball according to
mlbpipeline.com
he's pitched in front of the big
showcase audiences including the futures
game matt manning has arrived as of
tonight so great intrigue on both sides
of the scorecard in terms of the
starting pitching matchup and that
spills over into the stands where for
the first time it's full capacity at
angel stadium alex curry is on the field
and she's got more
thanks matt yeah today is an exciting
day at angel stadium because it's the
first time since 2019 that we are at
full capacity and we're calling it
reopening day now when we spoke to
angel's manager joe madden he said he
hopes this place is roaring and packed
shoulder to shoulder and it should be
because any time that the angel's
two-way superstar shohei ohtani is on
the mound it's an event and it feels
more like a rock concert than a baseball
game and the moment that the gates
opened today the energy has been
electric here at the big a but let me
give you a little insight into what it's
like when shohei ohtani is pitching
because the moment he walks out on the
field fans are lining the field and they
are going over to even watch his warm up
and they are lining the bullpen just to
get a glimpse to get a look to get a
smile of shohei ohtani and it doesn't
stop throughout the entire game they are
on their feet chanting his name when
he's on the mound and at the play as
they should be because he's doing things
we haven't seen in over a hundred years
so if you ever have a chance to come
watch shohiotani pitch in person do it
but if you're at home watching tonight
sit back grab a drink and enjoy the rock
show
we'd love to grab a drink alex you can
drink during a youtube game no no no
we're back for baseball this is going to
be a blast tonight tigers and angels 40
000 fans lineups in first pitch are next
[Music]
ripped to left staffer into the corner
grossman able to reset button
and cruising in with a lead off double
maybe that day off
and robbie grossman well
[Music]
he's always had a pretty good change up
that's going to drop in front of trump
grossman digging for second
and he's in there with a pop-up slide
now the 2-1
drives one to deep right field that ball
is history
a two-run blast by robbie grossman
and the tigers are kicking up their
heels in their half of the 11. robbie
crushes that ball
grossman lifts one to deep left field
fraley tracking it and that ball is gone
another bomb for robbie grossman and
robbie grossman has really been in a
group
he was kind of flat a week ago and
aj actually gave him a day off in
chicago
with another day off on monday he had a
couple days to rest and he's come back
with a vengeance ever since
[Music]
and welcome back presenting the tigers
lineup for this series opener brought to
you by chime grossman scope and
candelario off the top a lot of
left-handed passes and a lot of switch
hitters in aj hinch's lineup card
cabrera castro and haas four through six
akeel badu has been a great story he's
in left field banning number seven one
of the switch hitters willie castro at
second base banning eighth and that's
cameron the rookie center fielder rounds
things out
it is the 26 year old two-way wonder
shohei ohtani to make his 10th starting
assignment of the year most recently
friday in the desert
a five-inning start against the
diamondbacks in which he struck out
eight did not factor into the decision
of a six to five angels victory and
ohtani's out there tonight mark gubiza
to try to snap a three-game losing
streak as we are underway in anaheim
[Applause]
first pitch at 96 for shohei last time
out their first pitch was 95 there was a
discussion that maybe the velocity was
down a couple starts ago it is back up
there to his normal 95 99 range but he's
been ready hit this one
fastball misses and it's two balls and
no strikes to robbie grossman
grossman's hit safely in three in a row
and has been very hot of late
a big part of the tigers three-game
winning streak as they just got through
manhandling the kansas city royals
[Applause]
launches that one into the right field
corner ward looking up
and it's just fouled
boy over his career grossman has really
hit the angels pitching very very well
290 batting average slugging at 444 in
his career
versus the angels no matter what uniform
he has on he's been a pain
for the halos pitchers
definitely helps when you 2-0 on a
pitcher like this though
2-1 from otani misses high and away
well the tigers come here to start this
four-game series having not won a season
series against the angels in over a
decade
last time they claimed that was back in
2010
they are hot right now as we mentioned
finishing off a three-game sweep of
kansas city yesterday
[Applause]
and there's a first pitch walk issued by
ohtani
how about some more information on
ohtani gooby the chime breakdown of
tonight's angel starter
yeah really he's had to improve fastball
command it's been 92.99 he'll throw a
cut fastball to get it back in the
strike zone dominate with a splitter a
60 width percentage 0.63 batting average
and limit the free passes last 11
innings is two walks but before that 26
walks over 36 in the third innings pitch
for
showway ohtani so he's going back here
with that struggle in the first inning
for the first battle of the game with a
free pass
lead off fitter report for the tigers
now for jonathan scope
[Applause]
you know the angels have seen this from
otani to begin games in the past gooby
the fact that his command isn't perfect
in the first inning
the strikeout totals come for him
sometimes second time through the order
when he starts to use the split finger
fastball which has been unhittable this
year
he tries to use to get back into counts
to throw a slider especially early in
the first inning because this fastball
has run a little bit too much round then
you'll see maybe at some point he'll
start using his cut fastball
he's trying to slow down his delivery
sometimes he'll be caught in between
that quick delivery that slide step and
trying to bring that leg up and have
better balance
two balls and no strikes to count to
jonathan scope
off the knob of the bat fouled and it's
two and one
odds courtesy of fanduel and they've
posted a strikeout total for rotani
tonight of seven and a half
pay up for the over
keep a total running on that he struck
out eight as last time around on friday
against the diamondbacks
[Applause]
two balls in a strike to count to
jonathan scope
[Applause]
so in order to process all that
strikeout information know this that the
tigers swing and miss
quite a bit
so probably not a good idea to try to
steal bases because we might be looking
at a double play here
and uh with the ohtani on the mound it's
going to be very difficult to try to
steal bases
he looks very fast we're very quick to
the plate
[Applause]
scope lines that one foul
the tigers do like to run roger it's a
good point because aj hinch told us
before the game
that because they're not a big power
hitting team he likes to send base
runners he likes to push as many buttons
as he can not necessarily always in
straight steel contexts
but he tries to move people he'll hit
and run he will try to be aggressive
tonight
yeah i think the right pitch
right count
makes a difference
2-2 to scope is hammered fouled man he
is spraying foul balls all over the
ballpark
nice early on ohtani having a tough time
with his feel for his secondary pitches
splitter that one before was pulled foul
that slider he got underneath it it's a
time where he'll try to sneak a fastball
on the outside part of the plate at the
knees
[Applause]
still two balls and two strikes to the
dh jonathan scope a full count now
[Applause]
here might be a good id good idea to
maybe get the the runner runner going
get get get that batter you know making
contact
get get some action going get get some
infielders
moving maybe out of position
who knows what could lead to
grossman stays put and it's a swing and
a miss probably a good thing they didn't
send him there scope strikes out
two long played appearances for rotani
one away with a runner on
that's going with a splitter here starts
and then drops off the outside corner
he's swinging miss
interesting how he holds his splitters
as compared to some other pitchers he's
right on the seams with his fingers and
able to drop that one down and out of
the strike zone
well your point on running against
ohtani is well taken roger he has
allowed only three stolen bases in his
career he is fast to the plate
yeah those are those are the odds you
don't want to take as a base dealer
those that's when okay you're going to
shut it down you're going to look for
other opportunities
to either get to the next base uh
whether that's balls in a dirt so now
you're looking for
that that splitter when it gets to two
strikes to run and kind of anticipate
that ball in the dirt
there's jammer candelario now he too was
hit safely in three in a row to start
the game tonight
and then there's opportunities where you
know
when the catcher is not paying attention
he's getting lazy where you can actually
delayed steal
if the catcher is not paying attention
but this this catches thrown about
he seems to be aware of what's going on
candelario squares around it
foul
let's take a look at our stack ass 3d
powered by google cloud where hit
splitter has been located look how many
swings have been below the strike zone
chases oh 63 batting average four for
64. a few of them will leave upstairs
you track it up there out of the strike
zone and still has that ability to drop
in here but a lot of those swinging
misses well below the strike zone
and he'll throw that split to both sides
of the plate too
he does not discriminate
fallen two strikes to candelario now
i think you almost have to expect a
splitter right here
i think you almost have to look for the
ball up against ohtani with all those
balls going down in the zone you have to
look for the ball up
and make sure he gets it up
like that
middle away and it's a base hit and a
center field so candelario's aboard on a
two-strike count
and the tigers have something cooking in
the top of the first
[Applause]
yeah this this splitter just stays up
more tumbling rolling action usually you
think of his splitter going straight
down that had more of a running action
going away almost like a circle change
up just like that roger like you said
you got to look for a pitch like that
elevated enough where you can get the
good part of the battle and that's
exactly what cardinality was able to do
hit that up the middle for a base hit
[Applause]
so two runners aboard now for the future
hall of famer miguel cabrera
one of the most decorated hitters in the
modern history of the game two-time
a-l-m-v-p
four-time batting champ an 11-time
all-star
and at the age of 38 digging in for the
first time against shohei oh county and
taking a fastball for a strike
numbers have come down of course in his
senior statehood
but there is no denying the fact that
miguel cabrera is one of the most
impactful right-handed batters that the
game has seen in the last 50 years
[Applause]
following a strike
[Applause]
what a hit of this is though and a great
teammate
[Applause]
is he the only guy left from uh from
your two years as a tiger he's got to be
it he's he is the one guy that's left
and he was he was really we were really
close locker mate so i really got to
know maggie
in the locker room he's a fun guy fun
personality he's he's always you know
comes ready to play he seems like he
walks up gets out of bed bit boy he can
hit he can swing it um
obviously you know with the injuries
with his ankle and
all these other injuries those
those affect the player especially
as you get older yeah i would imagine
well cabrera hitting just 216 this year
five homers 25 rbis
and you know the way he started the
season with a homer against the indians
on a snowy opening day afternoon
everybody thought oh man this is going
to be old miguel cabrera
the returns haven't been quite as good
since that opener and a fastball just
poured right past it couldn't catch up
three fastballs strike out a guy that's
known as one of the better fastball
hitters in baseball
yeah roger is that one of those cases as
a hitter you're thinking splitter or
slider here and you end up getting a
fastball right down the heart of the
plate normally that ball is crushed by
miggy but he would look looked like he
was looking for something all speed oh
absolutely probably looking for the ball
up and and and it makes maybe he his his
bat might have slowed down over the
years and he might want to start looking
looking for the
looking for that that hard stuff
pitches that he can get to a lot of
times
hitters will look in inside for the
inside fastball to get them ready for
anything else they if they if they can
get ready and girl for that the hard
stuff
it makes it a little bit easier to hit
the off speed stuff
so two out two on for harold castro now
you know aj hinch told us before the
game that miguel
cabrera is
swinging us a slightly
lighter bat
in kind of you know trying to make those
adjustments that you talk about older
guy now can't get around on the heater
as well as he might used to have
a ball in the strike to count to castro
and harold castro sends a high fly ball
out to right for taylor ward
two left stranded in the visitors half
of the first
underway at angel stadium
no score
[Music]
left field on a fastball here comes
ohtani ben and tandy uncorks it to the
plate not in time one to nothing halo
it's another rbi number 600 of his
career for anthony rendon
that level swing drives the ball toward
right toward that wall it's down off the
base of the wall then anthony rendon
a pair with a couple of bases flexing
that leg
rendon hits it hard into center field
shohei makes the turn come on down the
angels at another
3-2 pitch to rendon a swing and a drive
to left field that one is gone
rendon's fourth of the year gets the
angels on the board in the fourth inning
today rindon said all right you want to
try it again this time you're going to
pay the price for it and for rendon
boy that has been a long time coming
[Music]
first pitch from clark into the right
center field gap that's going to score
both
often and easily statsy right behind him
it's a one-run ball game that didn't
take long
[Music]
welcome back the angels lineup brought
to you by chime here's how joe madden
aligns the home side justin upton shohei
ohtani and taylor ward off the top great
numbers for shohei otani is a hitter on
knights when he's doing double duty
walsh suzuki and wong fourth through six
legarres renifo and fletcher rounded out
no anthony rendon still nursing a
triceps injury
and jose iglesia is getting a scheduled
night off tonight and of course mike
trout we hope to hear from a little bit
later on
still working his way back to full
health here's the other part of the big
story tonight ron jay it's matt manning
making his major league debut tonight
exciting stuff yes out of sacramento you
know he has his family his friends you
know they're all
from the state of california they're
they're they're going to be in
attendance
and this has got to be some kind of
nerves going through his body
matt manning's first pitch in the big
leagues misses inside to justin upton
and it's not like you can hide as a
starting pitcher right as as you come in
as a get called up as a big as a
position player you have at bats you can
hide you know and get away from the
crowd
but when you're coming in as a starting
pitcher
you have the ball in your hand those
nerves are going you know your your
palms are sweating or whatever you do
but that is is it's it's it's a scary
moment but it's an exciting moment at
the same time all eyes on you
all eyes on you
two balls and distract the count to
justin upton
well manning rated as we mentioned as
the number 18 overall prospect in major
league baseball ranked as detroit's
number three prospect
behind spencer torkelson riley green two
basic household names in the prospect
stratosphere and it's three balls in a
strike to upton now
[Music]
mackenzie gore nate pearson and we're
talking about some of the
the blue chip prospects in our sport
[Applause]
upton chops it to third for candelario
manning comes back after falling behind
three and one to get his first down
chime breakdown on the rookie
right-hander gooby remember yeah trust
him that movement on his mid-90s
fastball stay under control use that
movement to get chases on his break and
stuff especially his knuckle curveball
in this like roger that you got to slow
things down and just take that deep
breath and breathe and relax let the
muscles just relax and be able to have
better stuff especially with his
fastball
aj hinch telling us before the game that
his rookie right-hander will not be
afraid tonight
here's shohei ohtani 19 homers
getting to that figure with homers in
back-to-back games tuesday and wednesday
in oakland
to add to that point of not being afraid
3-1 to justin upton
a power guy goes right after him
with a 3-1
pitch
and got that out that's that's that's a
that's a big relief as as a as a rookie
coming up just to get that first out
two balls in the strike to count to
ohtani
19 homer's 47 runs batted in
one of the top slugging percentages in
the game
a slam dunk for the all-star game
all-star balloting is open and we'll
talk about it throughout our telecast on
youtube tonight
it couldn't be any easier to vote for
your favorite players this year
[Applause]
so manning behind ohtani as he was upton
and this time the 3-1 pitch misses and
ohtani's aboard
yeah it's amazing how patient ohtani has
been over his last 15 games or so
early in the season he's up there
hacking he laid off a change up down
make it 3-1 and a fastball in a
change-up for a young pitcher making the
debut is the hardest pitch because
everything is just
amped up and trying to rush it home and
a change-up is one of those field
pitches to slow your body down he won't
be able to do that and it kind of
affected the next pitch on his fastball
yeah manny's gonna have to work on that
command as these these guys are
it will make him pay if he keeps getting
behind an account
taylor ward's up there swinging
and a first pitch fly ball out to right
robbie grossman has time under it for
route number two
[Applause]
it's good to see the young by the way
guys
ohtani said he wants to try to steal the
base on the day he's pitching and joe
man to keep saying he doesn't want him
to take that chance and waste energy
trying to steal a base but shohei
as we said in the open you just never
know with him always expect the
unexpected for showing ohtani already
with 10 stolen bases this year oh it's
got to be tempting as jared walsh takes
it i mean you got a guy making his major
league debut on the mound a rookie
catcher behind the plate and ohtani's
one of the fastest guys in the majors
looks like some quid pretty quick feet
by the by the pitcher manning right
there so this that might keep him a
little bit closer to the base
[Applause]
that's one thing as a base dealer you
look for those quick feet those athletic
pitchers
wall shortens up and waves through a
bunt it's nothing and one to jared walsh
who's got big power numbers this year
15 homers 46 rbis
the angels are the only team in baseball
with multiple players
that both have at least 15 homers and 46
driven in walsh and ohtani
one and one
as much as you love to see walsh you
know especially with the shift on using
that bunt you have kurt suzuki on deck
and the power that walsh has you want
him swinging away trying to go extra
bass especially on all speed pitches
this year he's slugging 8 41
and really good at home
also
[Music]
[Applause]
not a bad device for manning just to get
him
again
a little eased into the game tonight
he's thrown 13 pitches 11 of them
fastballs and jared walsh is a dead red
fastball hitter
like that
right on the button but right at the
dude to retire the side
nothing comes with the one-out walk a
zero posted by matt manning in his major
league debut
salvi smoked the line drive to left
field for a single his first time up off
of school
now salvi hits it high and deep to left
field grossman is back
gone for a two run home run
leave it to salvador perez to clean it
up and get that lead back willy castro
stands in with a runner on first and
nobody down
here's the 3-2
a drive to right center field that falls
deep that ball is gone right away willie
willie castro with a two-run shot to tie
it up at three
hope
and it gets by gallagher and grossman's
gonna score the tigers take the lead
another one
that one
shot just passed the diving hands or
alberto
taylor cuts it off but not in time to
get candelario who scampers home nomar
mazzara has an rbi single and it's a 6-3
tigers lead
those are the numbers against michael
fuller three homers as many strikeouts
as hits
there he goes here's the o2 swung out of
this boy michael and he strikes out
perez on three pitches to end it and the
tigers sweep the royals
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back top of the second with
angel's two-way superstar shohei ohtani
on the mound now in his last start on
june 11th in arizona he took a foul ball
off of his leg after getting checked out
by the angels medical staff he shook it
off stayed in the game and went on to
hit a double but the big question was if
he would return to the mound following
that minor injury and you bet he did
showing that grit now shohei is not only
dominating the stat sheet on both sides
of the ball but what you don't see in
the box score is that competitive edge
and just how tough he is and matt i
think the best part is we're seeing him
show emotion this season and he's really
just having a great time out there on
the field it's a great point alex and
it's been a range of emotions from
competitive to disappointed
to even apologetic have you ever seen a
guy apologize to an opponent for robbing
them of a base hit as this guy did when
he took one away from austin meadows at
this ballpark last month he apologized
to him
perhaps that's part of the coach here
it yeah you're probably right uh but you
know it's also
i i just think he's a great sportsman
right he he competes the proper way
and is having a great time doing it
back to work
starts eric haas with a breaking ball
for a strike
has getting uh opportunity to play now
it's it's exciting
i got to got to play with him with well
with
the indians and uh he didn't get to play
that much but you could see the power
chopper going to be a tough play for ren
heapho gets it to first in time hey haas
can run
maddie going to say it again about
catcher being able to run a little bit
runs well for a catcher there it is
yes there you go
and ring hifo just recalled today made a
nice play on that one
yeah the angels making a roster move
today
bringing renjifo up from triple a salt
lake
optioning right-handed reliever aaron
slagers
back to the farm
the angels are hoping to have
anthony brendon back tomorrow
there was a chance that he would have
been out there tonight
first ball swinging is a keel badou and
that one's into right field
but due showing that flash he's around
second on his way to third
throw there is
in time
i like the aggressive
boy this from our angle here i mean that
was as bad as textbook as you can do as
far as getting to the relay man
did everything right you've got to press
the issue when you're facing something
like shohei ohtani you've got to try to
take that extra base aj hints told us
that before the game they're going to be
aggressive that's a slider this out over
the plate taylor ward a first round pick
as a catcher
throws that in the red heap of him right
on the money good tag by ken wong great
on the back the throw gets him at third
base you can't play that any better as
far as hitting your relay man all the
way through and that's the right time to
make to to actually go extend and try to
get a triple on that
with with badou i mean with one out
you want you want a man on third with
less than two outs
two gun bases empty now for the switch
hitter willy castro man that is it about
as beautiful
a play at a base as you're going to see
exactly that was a great strong throw by
the second baseman right on the money
just getting called up and make a play
like that that's going to impress your
manager and badou can run let's make no
mistake he's very fast
on the ground to the right side of the
infield walt's very good over there to
ohtani covering
a couple of good plays one you can
really put a star on
nothing in the tigers half of the second
[Applause]
[Music]
now show here johnny batting
the base is empty
well
and that one did it again
got him
breaking ball
wow how strong he is i just love that
that facial expression as he crushes
that baseball so here is ramon well it's
standard practice now that the laser
gets himself a knock right it's this one
the left it's hit well
and that baby's gone
deep
he makes a home run he saves the run and
drives it around with one swing in the
back and here's pinder hinder hitting
for brown
and that's a line drive base in left
field lowry's being waved home lowry's
gonna score and this game is tied at
four so the bases will be loaded with
nobody out yep
shallow center a thing of beauty
chapman comes in to score and
is looking for some contact here which
would likely give the is their seventh
run
fletcher's coming home the throw is high
everybody's safe anders scores and it's
7-4
[Music]
welcome back to the game of the week on
youtube presented by chime the tigers
have won three in a row and yesterday it
was rookie southpaw tarik skubal that
really wrapped things up an outstanding
start six innings into the afternoon
scattered
six hits and struck out seven for his
fourth winner of the year he is a big
part of why there's so much optimism
around the young tigers staff hey
left-hander how you doing
good how are you hey we're doing great
well i'm used to only hearing the voice
through mlb the show it's this is crazy
oh yeah well hey man uh it's it's good
to have you with us thanks for taking
some time we got a
really fast first pitch out first of all
tell us about you how you feeling i mean
here we are in mid-june give us the
status update and your rookie run
through the grande leagues
yeah you know i'm the only thing i'm
really focused on and worried about is
just being healthy you know that's all i
can ask for and i'm healthy and strong
right now so you know you know i really
like where i'm at when i'm healthy i can
you know work on things and get better
at the game so that's all i can ask for
[Applause]
one gun that'll bring in key and wong
matt manning making his big league debut
tonight
and you know this young staff that the
tigers have put together tarik i mean
with
the names that you guys have put
together in
prospects all of you
uh are you are you guys
like tight as a unit does everybody kind
of evan flow in their own way give us a
sense for your group
yeah you know i think we're all pretty
close um you know when we were together
in erie and in double a and 19 you know
we all got pretty close by the end of
the year just you know rolling in and
competing with each other
um i thought that was a ton of fun and
now to have matt making his debut
tonight you know it's a ton of fun to
have him around and
and you know i'm i think i'm more
nervous than him watching him pitch
right now honestly but uh you know it's
a ton of fun to have these guys around
me
yeah turk mark uber's out here i was
just wondering is a pitcher watching his
today a major league debut for matt were
you able to talk to him before the game
or even last night say listen this is
what you got to expect that first time
out there
i just you know told him to go and enjoy
it and have fun you know you only get to
do this once you only debut once so
just enjoy it and have fun
wong with a base hit back up the middle
but he turns into two
that looked like nothing more than a
single and wong ends up at second base
that's that aggressive base running
taking advantage of a of a outfielder
that put his head down and was not
charging the ball hard
that's when the outfitters get lazy and
they stopped charging the ball they get
lazy and then they find out oh he's
there
that's the kind of base running
that is aggressive that forces errors
that makes that force the defense to
make plays
wong at second base with one god for
juan lagares whose first homer as an
angel came this week
hey tarik so you're a northern
california guy
uh
a's or giants growing up
bays ace for sureness eric chavez barry
zito those are my guys growing up those
are my idols oh now we're now we're
talking about the left for sure the
left-handers fraternity with zito have
you ever met the former cy young award
winner
i have not but i would love to i would
love to meet him and just
talk about anything doesn't need to be
about baseball you know not a boy
you can talk about playing the guitar
he's got a musical background to him as
well right he's kind of a renaissance
man really
oh that would be a ton of fun who have
been your biggest pitching influences
or anybody out there
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean
i mean i watch zito a lot but you know
you watch just left-handed pitchers you
know i in college i watched paxton
because i went to school in seattle and
he was there and
watching him how he would attack guys
and i i kind of tried to model after him
a little bit
but at the same point just trying to be
yourself out there and and whatever
feels good feels good but you know i
just like watching guys i like watching
all guys you know it doesn't matter if
you're left-handed or right-handed just
watch guys go out there and compete it's
a ton of fun to watch
[Applause]
here's luis runhifo now with two out and
a runner at second
[Applause]
renjifo has already shined on the
defensive side of the scorecard tonight
with a great relay to nail akil badu
trying to stretch an extra base
just one for 14 to the big league level
but good triple a numbers for rendifoe
this year 30 games a 331 batting average
and five dingers
2-0
[Applause]
and there goes when you sit there in the
dugout i know you're watching your
friend there in matt manning pitching
but do you ever find yourself being a
fan of what you're seeing from shohei
ohtani but on the mount and swinging the
bat too
[Applause]
yeah i think you know i was talking to
some guys like he's a great arm but i
think i was more excited to watch him
hit for some reason like
just what he's doing for the game is
incredible and then you know watching
him just cover first base he is a big
human being a very athletic human being
too so you know it's incredible to watch
him do what he does on a daily basis
is there anybody that you faced this
year tarek where you you kind of had to
just shake yourself and be like wow i'm
facing this dude i grew up watching him
[Applause]
yeah i think last year um
nelson cruz and paul goldschmidt were
probably one of the two guys that
i was like wow you know these are the
guys that
i feel like i've looked up to forever
and goldschmidt being from arizona when
he was in arizona i just
idolized him going up through high
school so i think those two guys i was
like wow you know step off a little bit
take another deep breath and then just
try to focus back up terry this is raje
out here man i i've been impressed
watching that explosive fastball that
you've been throwing past these some of
these right-handed pitchers are hitters
you know is that is that something that
you pride yourself on is is being able
to command that fastball i see you come
in on on on right-handed hitters and
you establish that inside it what what
is that for you that you have fastball
i think it's everything you know getting
guys uncomfortable in up and in standing
guys out you know breaking posture
because it opens up the rest of the
plate you know the last thing you want
is just hitters
i know the last thing you want is
hitters to be comfortable
face it through the hole juan coming
around to score throw gets away from
haas at the plate it's an extra 90 feet
for red heapho and the angels are the
first to score tonight
[Applause]
he got a fastball that was elevated i
don't think manny wanted to throw that
fastball there before his lateral move
but he stayed back on it and punch out
the left field otherwise that nasty
fastball he has would get him off the
end of the bat but that was elevated
enough where he's able to get the barrel
up he's got a base head
that's a ball where the the outfielder
coming in on that ball has to get that
ball down he has to hit the cutoff man
that ball has to be down now you're
giving guys extra basis this is what
loses ball games this is what cost
guys teams
losses
david fletcher hits the hole on the
right side that scores ren and he foe
two nothing angels
and it feels gooby like the angels
lineup
is sitting on the heater here because
manning has thrown 28 pitches now 23 of
them fastballs and fletcher went up
there looking for it
look at those eyes wide open there with
runners in scoring position he's
probably the best hitter on the angels
team you think of all the power guys
upton
you know you got ohtani rendon when he's
in there trout when he's in the most
consistent
david fletcher with runners in scoring
position
chris chris federer is out the pitching
coach of the tigers to just kind of chat
with matt manning here
his first bit of adversity in his major
league debut
you see the aggressive play that has
really led to this these couple of runs
scoring
with the
[Music]
[Applause]
just the the hustle double
and then you have the
the overthrow where he goes all around
the second he's gonna he goes
second overthrow
now he's in position to go to third and
that just leads to bigger enemies now
you have the bigger boys coming up to
bat and that's just dangerous dangerous
indeed is justin upton especially on
a fastball here we go with fletcher at
first base hey tarik we're going to let
you go with two out in the inning thanks
for joining us good luck tuesday against
the cardinals man thanks for visiting
with us
i appreciate it guys thanks for having
me thanks derek derek scooble joining us
on the team
and unfortunately it comes
in an inning where the angels are
treating his buddy pretty poorly here
and justin upton's behind 01.
[Applause]
you know the numbers for manning were
not terrific at triple a and aj hinch
was quick to point out that look we're
not just looking at numbers this is a
live arm a top prospect he's here
because of two things
need and the fact that he is a prospect
and he's earned the opportunity
that last start you talked about it
earlier roger was his best at triple a
this year and they felt like the time
was right
yes uh that's that's that's the kind of
start you want to be able to build off
he can remember
you know the the the good things he did
in that in that start
you're hoping that he would take that
into this his next start
[Applause]
1-1 breaking ball up and fouls it away
and i'm going to guess here gooby that
the conversation with chris fedor may
have had something to do with using the
secondary pitches now second time
through the order
yeah oh yes and that's the pitches i
mentioned that before as far as feel the
secondary is when you have that
adrenaline going it's so difficult to
have that feel you want to think you
could throw a fastball by anybody but
the secondary pitches are the ones going
to set up the fastball that's a good
idea to use it see that's it right there
wow he slipped a 95 mile an hour heated
right past upton who was not looking
fastball
two in the angel second however
to the third inning in anaheim two
nothing for the home side
he struck him out save that baseball
that's his first at the major league
level good for jason foley
one away
panager drives one to left field badou
gives chase reaches out and makes the
grab
great closing speed right there for
purdue
cabrera laces one down the left field
line
that's into the finger
cabrera will dig for second will trot in
there he's got himself a one-out double
his foot 584th
of his major league career deep center
field hill going back and that ball is
[Music]
hill with a spectacular play in center
field
wow
that's right
instead he swings it
deep right field
get up it's gone
his first
[Applause]
that's worth sticking around for it
i'm telling you
you gotta say it that's awesome
397 feet
[Music]
hey welcome back some notable impressive
starts around major league baseball in
addition to shohei ohtani's opening to
the season vladimir guerrero jr leading
the league in homer's fernando tatis jr
and how about jacob grom did do i get
this right did degrom gooby in his last
start was out there for three innings
and he struck out eight is that what i
heard yes
he's unreal he's not he's like showing
he's not of this world i don't think
yeah it's
unbelievable what he's been able to do
um i like i like i like
i like guerrero
there's nothing not to like man 22
homers
leading the way for a really fun young
dynamic team this is our first poll
question of the night and we'll put a
bunch of these up on the screen for you
to chime in and vote at home who has
been the most impressive player this
year so far take your pick no wrong
answers by the way
you know watching you know
guerrero in in aaa a couple years ago
man i thought he was the best player on
the plane he was hitting like 4 20. he
we just couldn't get him out he if we
pitch to him he hit he's hitting rockets
everywhere if we don't pitch him he's
walking
[Applause]
what i love about all four of them they
all love the game show emotion have fun
besides the fact they're incredibly
talented but they enjoy going out there
and competing on a daily basis
cameron leads things off in the tigers
half of the third
sends a fly ball out to wright for ward
speaking of legacies vlad junior and his
hall of fame dad
daz cameron's dad had a terrific major
league career mike cameron major league
veteran
gold glover
and a guy i can i'm convinced
you had to watch
every day to really appreciate how good
mike cameron was man he was a great
player oh yeah
well four home run game right oh that's
four run game that's what i think about
when i think about
oh dad right there
okay
one gun now for the top of the order
robbie grossman who takes a strike
[Music]
robbie grossman's been hot
he's recorded a multiple hit game in
five of his last nine starts average up
to 247 after kind of a rocky start to
the year
came aboard on a two-year deal after
some good seasons in oakland
and he was a guy that really connected
the oakland lineup not the most
talked-about player there
but a guy who was really important and a
guy who has an oakland a gooby had some
big nights against the angels
big on on the one guy he always wanted
not up at the plate against the angels
patient on base percentage 360 this year
he's going to make you those are
striking always working counts
he's one in a number of players this
year who doesn't really strike you
as your typical leadoff guy
but he gets on base he's comfortable at
the top of the lineup so
you know
lead off hitters don't look like they
used to they're not all little guys that
run
exactly
they're guys that they can get on base
for them big boppers they hit them wrong
see the angels playing him and his shift
really
favoring the right side of the infield
and it's three and two to robbie
grossman i bet he wants that pitch back
you know you get a pitch 3-1 you know
what's coming
i mean he's going to challenge you he
challenges him with a fast ball and he's
and he's late on
what do you get
[Applause]
i imagine he comes back with a split now
that lower third yeah
this is where as a hitter you're
thinking okay
do i be aggressive or not aggressive is
is is he gonna go for the strikeout or
is he not
3-2 pitch
got him
it looked like grossman got caught in
between there
he wasn't sure if he was going to throw
it in the dirt that's why that's what
you got you just look for the ball up
and if it's up bam go for it
yeah he looked like he went back door
slider he was in maybe anticipating a
split and it stayed in that
kind of an upper plane and then that
late break on the back side of the plate
gets a swing and miss at 83 82
that's like unfair you know 97 in and
then i'm gonna go change up away
so here's jonathan scope a strikeout
victim in his first try
[Applause]
you know the thing with ohtani in a
two-strike count too rajay you you we
just kind of talked around it
you start to guess a little bit
you might think you can eliminate
something you really can't in two strike
counts opponents are seven for 96
against him
yeah that's
[Applause]
here's a two-strike count to scope
yeah the eyes are going to be
i mean
you're seeing a lot of all-speed pitches
now first pitch against ohtani do you
possibly sit off speed first pitch
against him
i think with him you you you always have
to look for that that heater
[Applause]
because you know it's going to come
eventually
and you have to you have to i mean
because that's it that's really his his
his best pitch is his fastball and and
off that fastball he's able to pitch
effectively with his off speed
it's a ball and two strikes to jonathan
scope trying to pick up a three-game
hitting streak tonight two and two
but some guys
having said that they might see
be watching the game and see that and
say oh i'm i'm going to take this this
one shot and i'm gonna i'm gonna sit on
and off speed this one pinch or or
that's what some some hitters do
got him to chase
threw him a slider there in a two-strike
count
four punch-outs for shohei otani through
three
to the bottom of the third and it's two
nothing for the shohei show
[Music]
[Applause]
santana lifts that with left field
justin's got a long way to go still
going
with the catch
attaboy jay up
long going back to the wall up against
it leaps keene wong hello
pulling it back into the yard
left field on the fastball here comes
ohtani ben and he uncorks it to the
plate not in time one to nothing halo
that's another rbi number 600 of his
career for anthony rendon
iglesias squares one up that's hit well
to center field
marta can't make the
[Applause]
this is what they got they got that
fight
they were up there trying to do as much
damage as they could there's damage
right there
[Applause]
goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back two nothing lead for the
angels and it's really our pleasure to
have mike trout on with us to take some
time hey mike how we feeling how you
doing today man
feeling good feeling good about to watch
this ohtani homer right here hey uh you
know what let me ask you this about
ohtani man because we marveled at this
guy as i know you do what was the first
moment when you realized how fast he was
how fast he was uh
any ball in the gap you know he's
getting a triple uh anything down the
line
um
i think the most impressive thing is the
balls that you know hit up the middle
that he's just beating out regularly you
know routine ground balls
little mike no it's fun to watch i
actually i actually got uh asked today
if i could win in a race against him i
don't know i don't think so
i think he's got me
mike trout this is raj davis here man
hey
it's been a pleasure watching you though
but
one thing and
one one thing one thing i have for you
man it's uh
it's
it's you know um i just lost my train of
thought what happens every once in a
while man
it happens
hey by the way mike raj is making his
broadcast debut today
and he's crushing it oh yeah yeah
it's a good start
except for that one
apologize for that
no that's all good
three balls in there
nice look what excites you more
watching trouty i mean watching shohei
on the mound or at the plate
[Applause]
uh it's got to be the plate man
for me i mean it's fun playing behind
him in center field but
i enjoy watching the hit man it's it's
uh it's pretty impressive i i know what
it is now chad
i'm back already oh you got it you got a
bad guy
i'm back hey man talking talking about
talking about ohtani well how is he the
clubhouse is he the kind of guy where
does he does he speak english like or
do you guys communicate like that on
that level
uh
yeah he's starting to get better um
it's kind of like
you have a conversation with him and
he'll know what you're saying but i
don't know if he can you know
get a sentence together obviously he's
got ipe but uh i think he knows more
english than people think
he's a great dude in the clubhouse
very humble dude
just does his work comes in every day
works hard and you don't really hear
much from him just sits in the corner
and uh you know like i said he's a great
teammate
trouty i remember last time when jerry
walsh is coming up he's on deck you were
saying he was going to hit a home run
i'm going to put you on the spot here
when he comes up again uh what are you
still calling a big fly from uh
jared washington
again looking on a fastball drive i was
over i was i was over one with otani
right there but uh
now i love the way washi was it has has
been this year is unbelievable too man
he uh comes in every day working hard
extremely hard wants to get better each
and every day
and uh seriously
this guy got a hit the other day with my
bat and he won't stop talking about it
sandoval
no i'm going to say washi man he's uh
washed he's been great great for his
team
hey mike what's it been like having fans
back in the ballpark is it is it just
like you know the way it's supposed to
be or was it weird
no it's not supposed to be um obviously
no fans
was tough i mean we feed off at players
feed off especially later in later later
in the summer
you're feeding off the energy from the
crowd and obviously full capacity
tonight it's uh
it's pretty electric tonight let's get
some offense going
hey mike how are you doing as far as
your uh recovery from your calf injury
how as far as you know it's the update
as far as when we're gonna see you back
on the field
yeah no it's going good i feel great um
obviously got to be smart i talked to
some doctors and uh
yeah i just gotta i gotta let them know
they're telling me what to do
i guess i got somebody talking to my ear
right now i just gotta listen to doctors
and if they tell me i go out there and
start running jogging i'm gonna listen
to them but i feel great uh hopefully
start some baseball activity in the next
few days and uh go from there
a trout i i have to have to break back
to remember remembering um
back into when i was in toronto i think
you were a rookie
um you were you had like
we were we were like neck and neck and
stolen bases
and i mentioned something
i mentioned something to you about
stealing bases that day you went out and
stole two of them just to take that lead
and make sure you gonna win
yeah now when i first came up it was
like i got on first base i was going no
matter what um obviously
you know later in my career i wanted to
control my health obviously diving so
much but uh
you know we definitely was a good battle
back then for sure
it might because we're on we're on
youtube tonight big global audience and
it's uh it's about noon in japan and
there are a lot of folks watching shohei
tonight um i'm curious if you guys have
ever had like a cross-cultural food
exchange where he's introduced you to
some really exotic japanese dining like
some weird sushi and maybe you've handed
him a like a taylor ham egg and cheese
sandwich
uh nothing crazy but uh i actually just
noticed we got some like japanese jelly
beans in here
in the dugout that's the first time i
ever noticed in them and they're
actually pretty good okay i don't know
what they're called but uh
yeah i walked out here we got some
japanese candy but uh
no i'm a big sushi guy nothing nothing
crazy though he uh
you know he's he's a quiet dude man he
just does his own thing and just comes
in and prepares himself every other day
and uh
you know it's good you know i see him
every once in a while i come to the
hotel room and play cards and stuff
uh and you know it's a he's a good great
good viewer you get him you get him on
that jersey diet get him on the taylor
hammock and cheese protocol he'll never
be the same
[Applause]
and that retires the side as castro
makes the play hey mike thanks for the
visit today speedy recovery everybody
wants to see out there as soon as you're
ready to come shall we
thank you i appreciate you having me on
thanks mike
[Music]
he
just smokes it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
great baseball right there
and that one's gonna go
that ball was crushed
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this copyrighted telecast is presented
by authority of the office of the
commissioner and may not be reproduced
or retransmitted in any form and the
accounts and descriptions of this game
may not be disseminated without express
written consent
mlb game of the week live on youtube
tigers and angels and a select group of
youtube creators additional in-depth
thoughts providing viewers a unique
experience you can watch us on your
mobile device your computer your smart
tv or wherever you happen to be watching
us right now
hey we gave you a poll earlier and a no
wrong answers question who's been the
most impressive player to start the year
and shohei ohtani wins this one in a
landslide gooby
yeah you know what he's doing at the
plate
on the bases on the mound it's tough to
argue that
[Applause]
candelario ohtani falls as he fields the
throw to first takes walsh off the back
first off did you see that athletic play
from otani diving off the mound
getting up quick and making that throw
that's that's that's a difficult play
right there
[Music]
i mean he gets that baseball dives and
gets up quickly if hit throw is on the
money he's out of first base he got
there that quick and that strong of a
throw just kind of sailed on him at the
end and walsh unable to keep his foot on
the base but what a play that was by
shohei
both tigers hits tonight courtesy of
jamer candelario
a
punt single here in the fourth lead off
hitters aboard for the second time for
the tigers and here's miguel cabrera
he got to see him one time already
got that angle
remember the strikeout to cabrera back
in the first it was on three fastballs
you know some headers they just use that
first at bat to kind of get
to see where the with the release angle
is to release that
get that get a view of that that release
point
[Applause]
alex curry has more on miguel cabrera
yeah the great veteran that mickey is
after he struck out he was holding court
in the dugout and sharing what he saw
from otani with his teammates and the
adjustments he needs to make it his next
bat and then we saw mickey having some
fun with ohtani when he was on first
base guys
i think everybody that's played with or
against miguel cabrera loves the guy
like he just he still has fun here's a
guy at 38 years old roger we've talked
about the back of his baseball card
11-time all-star i mean he's done
everything in this game and he still
plays like a kid
and he's still having fun that is one
thing it's
that's kind of hard to teach because you
gotta you gotta love what you do you
gotta love coming to the ballpark you
gotta be really
obsessed with with the game of baseball
and and it's it's and it's
it's and it's hard to you know transfer
that into all the players you know and
that that's
why he's been such a so good for so long
well he's got a couple more years left
on his massive contract and he's 94 hits
shot oh man that got him in the helmet
or the
arm it just got away from ohtani
that's always scary that going up up and
in
into the batter's head and shoulder and
neck area those are scary scary moments
for
batters
looks like a splitter there
got away yeah he got underneath on the
splitter
yeah you're right it got him in the arm
mercifully
cabrera is okay
runners at first and second with nobody
out now for the left-handed hitting
shortstop harold castro
[Applause]
that's a bit of relief really really
good on the first pitch
[Applause]
and on the first pitch he sends a fly
ball to upton and left for the first
down
that's a bit of relief for for biggie
you you have two strikes on him and a
guy like ohtani who could put you away
easy with with the fastball and the
splitter that a lot of guys he gets a
lot of swinging misses on
for him to hit him right there is
[Music]
obviously with with with with the lack
of success with two strikes against
ohtani that's a that's a gift
two strike counts and runners in scoring
position
are when ohtani is it is at his absolute
meanest
with runners in scoring position like
there are now opponents are three for 29
with 18 strikeouts i mean he just does
not give it up
it seems like some some pitchers when it
gets to that moment they focus a little
bit more they concentrate a little bit
more
on what they're doing
[Applause]
eric haas with the bouncer up over the
middle it's going to turn into an inning
ending double play the angels were in
the perfect spot
first and second nobody out and detroit
is turned away in the fourth
there was a time where a base hit a ball
hit like that up the middle is a base
hit
[Applause]
[Music]
daniel norris's first love is baseball
so he spends most of his time painting
corners i think baseball is an art form
for sure and that's what i
want to be as an artist is i want to be
able to execute my art but his second
love is photography art's a big part of
my family my sister is an amazing artist
she does watercolor portraits my dad was
he's always been very talented with that
i mean he he builds bikes what norris is
building is an impressive portfolio of
portraits
authentic photos of people
each one telling a story
i want to try and tell their story
through their eyes hopefully that people
that have never obviously seen that
person before or never met them that can
have a better understanding of who the
person is a human on the inside through
that portrait
former teammate ian kinsler
the late al k line
an old boss
a total stranger
norris is a self-described adventurous
soul and every stop
is a photo op hobbies are there to
give you an outlet of just something
else you know that's mine
[Music]
me
two nothing angels say we've got another
poll question
bo jackson eight seasons in the big
leagues four seasons in the nfl
dion sanders nine seasons in the big
leagues 14 seasons
in the nfl
to continue celebrating shohei ohtani a
two-way baseball player how about a
two-sport star take your favorite pick
no wrong answers here again
were you a bo jackson guy or a dion
sanders guy rojo i was actually both bo
knows baseball bow knows football and i
was playing all of those
but dion sanders was my man i mean
because who could do that dance like he
did the dance okay
on his way to the end zone that is
gooby i'm curious your thoughts on this
one
yeah i'm sitting in the booth right here
i'm just i'm standing up right now
thinking vince scully and president
reagan were sitting in this exact same
booth in the 89 all-star game when they
were just trying to say something about
bo jackson and immediately hits a home
run to dead centerfield hit about a mile
i used to go to all the football games
with the raiders so beau was the most
unbelievable athlete i've ever seen as
far as that wow factor but shohei's
pushing that a little bit what he's
doing on the baseball diamond but beau
was this
i always say that god dropped the
perfect human being on the ground and
that was bo jackson because he could do
everything so incredibly well and not
even stress about it
if if i may uh give it a try here
that homer in the 89 all-star game
sounded something like this
and bo jackson says hello
there's kian wong with one god
wong singled and scored back in the
second in fact he turned a single into a
doubled
by hustling into second base as das
cameron took a little time to gather
that ball in
so kian's already played a role tonight
the base hit snapped him out of an o for
10.
two balls and no strikes from the rookie
right-hander matt manning
that aggressive play got them on the
board
oh gathered in by
castro what a fine play by harold castro
with shortstop
that was a nice play i wasn't sure if he
came up with it but he definitely came
down with that one
[Music]
[Applause]
so far in this game tigers play it's a
pretty impressive defense especially in
the infield yes that's what you call hot
picture ball pretty hard
here's juan lagar is now with two god
you know the easy part of this game for
an announcer is any ball hit up the
middle you just say you know hit to
castro
because
harold castro and willie castro
make up uh a very unusual combination in
fact
it's the first time that two dudes with
the same last name
have played shortstop and second in the
same game
since orlando and as drooble cabrera did
it with the 2011 indians
now these guys played second and short
once before this year before their
combination here's a base hit for
ligaris
tell you what guys now this watching
from this angle
[Music]
manny's really starting to settle down
you can see that good arm actually just
before that base hit by legarres i mean
you're seeing some great life 95 with
his fastball he's relaxed now
he's taking that deep breath he's
starting to use his secondary pitches
he's into the fourth inning here now
with two outs with a total of 56 pitches
thrown you're seeing why the tigers are
so high on him as far as they prospect
in the future part of this rotation
he
he's been four seam heavy to start the
game tonight first strike first pitch
strike rather to luis renifo we were
told that he had added a slider in the
offseason but we haven't seen a lot of
that so far tonight
he's thrown that pitch only four times
and rangiful behind 0-2
attacking that zone attacking the strike
zone right here
that's that's going to be effective now
he's got the hitter right where he wants
him
he can go upstairs
we can bounce something on
in the dirt
cfo chase i'm thinking that knuckle
curve may be coming
back to manning who makes a very
athletic play and gets through the side
despite the two out single
on to ending number five still two
nothing angels
so many people are so excited to see
these young men at 19 years old we
landed in l.a at like 6 30 4 7 and we
take a cab
to anaheim which is an hour away right
well here he is
center fielder mike trout his major
league debut tonight we had traffic to
get to anaheim we do not get to the
stadium
until the sixth or seventh inning
and we like running so listen here's the
other here's the killer so we tell them
mom says mike now leave us four tickets
we'll be
just we'll buy tickets just give us a
ticket somewhere
when we finally get in the stadium it's
like the top of the eighth inning
and a ball is hit the center
this one out toward right center and we
had just sat down mike trout giving
chase long run by trout he
runs it down
[Applause]
mike made that unbelievable catch out
the outfield holy smokes won a catch by
the kid
[Applause]
[Music]
has been the angels most potent hitter
and their best starting pitcher nine
assignments in era of 2.85
the rest of the group
a 5.43
era collectively and ohtani showing us
those flashes tonight
in four shutout innings so far against
the tigers
face the bottom of the order here in the
top of the fifth inning
scattered the three singles so far in
this game
two singles rather and one extra base
hit that was badou's double
where he was thrown out trying to
stretch it into a third base and here is
a keel for a second time tonight
what an unbelievable first week in
major league baseball akil badu had this
year
yes that was that was some kind of start
to your
major league career
i mean to go apple taco
on the first pitch was that the first
pitch that he saw first pitch first
pitch you ever saw in the big leagues
homer easy game right
i'm going to hit 70.
wait was that off the bench
i think he was a starter that day that's
a nice little piece of inside out
hitting there that nets him a leadoff
single he's two for two against ohtani
tonight
yeah after the homer on the first pitch
he ever saw the next night he had a
grand slam
the next night he had a walk-off single
and the night after that
a triple against a guy that finished
runner-up in the cy young voting last
year
like
he just dominated
that's that's when
when you come up and you do that kind of
thing it's like man this game is easy
right
here's willy castro with badou aboard
and badou will run he's stolen seven of
eight
yeah i think he's got to go here i mean
ohtani's quick to the plate suzuki is
his struggle thrown out base dealer just
17
this year 23 in his career i think you
got to press the issue if you're the
tigers
it's tough to get a a good a good good
lead on otani because he's got quick
feet he's an athletic pitcher and he
gets that ball over there to the first
bait
really quick so you you really can't be
off that bag
too much
so getting a good jump is is going to be
difficult but
pitching picking the right pitch is
going to be the key
[Music]
[Applause]
kurt suzuki's at 17
as far as his caught stealing percentage
this year down from his career average
he's been otani's guy that has been his
personal catcher this year for all but
one start suzuki has been back there the
15-year veteran
suzuki has been really
just amazing you know just being
a teammate with him in oakland and
watching the daily grind that he would
do every single game because he was
catching all the games then and he would
after games he was getting in the ice
tub and he was
soaking that body
every single
game after every single game so
you know he's he's one of those guys
who's taking care of his body and that's
why he's still playing today
[Applause]
on the ground and taylor made for two
red heapos relay however didn't have a
lot on it and castro runs well enough to
beat it out
[Applause]
yeah so far this year shoei otani's
coming in this game only had one double
play turn behind him looked like that
was going to be the second of the game
but didn't get a lot on that throw as he
steps on the base for an heatho
way that infield defense was set up a
little bit longer to get to the bag for
ren hifo unable to turn it
joe thinking i had a double play another
one
castro busting hard down the line that's
that classic
hard nose just
pete rose you know just going to just
work hard and
hustle down the line those are those are
what managers look for those are those
are those what keep you in in innings
so here's dad's camera now with one out
one on
i'm getting back to your comments about
kurt suzuki taking care of his body
you said that like a guy that did not
take care of your body i've heard the
stories about you taking care of your
toes
i know those stories
you knew what your money makers were oh
yes i i
i had to take care of them feet because
them feet
took care of me
[Applause]
i knew that i knew that i knew that from
the beginning
another bouncer another chance for two
fletcher gets one in the second five
play by david fletcher
filling in for jose glacious at
shortstop
[Music]
[Applause]
speaks italian plays second plays short
and hits pitches that are thrown above
his head for doubles
max scherzer is on the mound for the
tigers tonight and he is looking to
become the first tigers pitcher since at
least 1916 to have a 10-0 record
and a swing and a miss and machado is
retired
now max again ready with the o2 swinging
a miss got him in the breaking ball
and the 2-2 pitch swinging to miss
dickerson chasing
and he got him so that'll be the fourth
strikeout scherzer has two in a row
now max ready with a 1-2 here it is
swing and a miss struck him out
dickerson goes down swinging for the
second time the runners will be on the
move here and we'll see what max has in
store
[Applause]
swinging a miss he struck him out are
another quality start for the tigers
so max scherzer is now 10-0 to start the
season the second time in tigers history
that's been done what a start for max
and what a game tonight tiger is a
winner at five to one
[Applause]
leading off for your angels
stop number 22
jj
[Music]
each week this season on our broadcast
will focus on a youtube content creator
featured in our live game commentary
section today our creator spotlight
shines on austin kleck on austin's
channel you can watch this angels fan
share his love of baseball with everyone
and as an angels fan i am sure a fan of
david fletcher leading things off
all right gooby your man beau
your kansas city pal won the poll
question tonight
hey guys one of the greatest stories the
game when bo jackson and yankee stadium
hit three home runs in a game and then
he dove for a line drive that dion
sanders hit the center field that he
though that's when he separated or
dislocated his shoulder
and dion got it inside the park home run
all the same games you saw both of them
with their athleticism on display in the
same game that was pretty cool to see
[Music]
one gun it's pretty fun watching manny
kind of settle in and get comfortable
and attack that zone and
kind of kind of he's starting starting
to get a little deep in this in this
game now
one out here in the fifth he'll face
justin upton for a third time
upton is grounded out and struck out
tonight
yeah you know
when we talked with aj hinch before the
game and he talked about manning gave us
a
little bit what to expect he said he's
the kind of guy that if he's on your
side
you love him but if he's on the other
side
he's going to bug you
and i think that's a really big
compliment to pay a player absolutely
you know you know a player like that is
going to go out there and compete no
matter who's in the box that he's facing
he's going to go out there and challenge
him see what see what he can do with his
stuff
he's frozen justin upton on fastballs a
couple of times tonight that was really
well located on the outside edge
he challenged them early
early on 3-1 count justin um grounded
that ball
to the third baseman but
struck him out for a second time on a
lively 95 mile an hour heater and he's
feeling it
his now velocity is picked up and his
comfort with his fastball and when you
look at
just enough that he's crushing breaking
balls this year he's had a tougher time
with fastball especially velocity
take a look at our stack 3d powered by
google cloud where he's been throwing
those pitch at 59 of the four scene
fastball 43 of them he's throwing seven
curveballs four sliders and five change
ups these challenge quite a bit
with 43 four seen fastballs and it's got
some life on it as the game has
progressed
it looks like it
the hitters are not picking it up that
well or at least up up
didn't didn't look like he was picking
the ball up that well
almond no strikes the count to shohei
ohtani who's walked and grounded out
tonight
rare change up that time from manning
and it's 2-0
some pitchers watch out for this swing
[Applause]
oh
yeah he was dialed up for it
[Applause]
upstairs with a fastball for seamer but
shohei can bring his hands up and hit a
high fastball very very well especially
if he hits it center the left center
it looks like his is fastballs playing
up a tick
with with the deception he's getting on
it with these swings the way that with
the way the hitters are reacting to his
fastball
and he loses ohtani for the second time
[Applause]
if a rookie right-hander making his
major league debut is a little reluctant
to give in on a strike this might be
part of the reason why
against jesus lizardo on tuesday in
oakland i mean that ball was clobbered
and then yesterday afternoon
in your old stomping grounds rodri
oh yes yes staying away from that hot
bat
probably not not always a bad idea
and and getting those guys that you know
you you have a better shot at
so now it's taylor ward who's batting
third by the way as high as he's hit in
the angels order tonight
again because of some notable absences
anthony rendon still nursing a triceps
injury
jose iglesias with a scheduled day off
and mike trout with whom we visited
earlier
still mending the calf injury
every time i look up it seems like it's
two outs now when
manning's on the bound
[Applause]
was on the move he was trying to steal
straight steal he wasn't even looking in
at the swing of joe madden looking and
going he just tried to steal the base as
a pitcher and here show a smile and go
back to the bag
look but look at those gloves
look at those gloves they look like nice
padded
stealing gloves i kind of wish i had
those when i was stealing them
yeah why didn't you wear those i didn't
i don't i don't think we had those that
that might be a different market
for for
ohtani
two balls in the strike this is what
happened when shohei got to first base
with miguel cabrera
[Applause]
that's
that's that's miguel cabrera all the
time
doesn't matter who it is
that's him all day
we'll check in at first base
by the way those gloves look like
something you could take into an mma
fight yeah exactly you know you got to
be careful sometimes sliding in head
first
you know with the tag
we had one player you know going head
first hands first and broke his hand
with with just a swipe of the tag
so that's
that that that's definitely going to
help out with protection
two and two
for me those gloves look like the gloves
that the characters wear at disneyland
across the street
you know you got the mickey and the mini
and they got the huge hands and they're
waving oh yes
yeah we know all about that
[Applause]
in the davis house though
two balls and two strikes to count to
taylor ward
mandy coming at him with high fast balls
and ohtani was running again
that's not even on the 3-2 that's a 2-2
count
remember he's pitching in this game
that's twice now
he's gone already and is it bad and
remember he's going to be taking the
mountain he's sixth inning
he's coming out of their house even
though they're smiling over there
yes
[Applause]
there he goes again and ward is locked
up on a 95 mile an hour heater
[Applause]
all that for nothing
and now he's got to go back out there
and pitch some more
still two-nothing angels
i think he won't
hang on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's done it
spencer turnbull
the eighth no hitter in tigers history
look at the love that the team is
showing him they're so happy for him
we're all happy for him heck everybody
in the stadium is happy for him
here's the payoff
fly ball left field frazier going back
measuring it that ball is good
[Applause]
you can't make this stuff up this is
beautiful
[Applause]
yeah baby
that's worth sticking around for it
you gotta say it that's awesome
[Applause]
okay
come on out to the big a on tuesday june
22nd as the angels face the giants at 6
30 the first 14 000 fans receive an
angels rally monkey courtesy of oc
healthcare agency for more info visit
angels.com
slash promotions
show hey otani so far in the night on
the mound five shot at innings he's been
helped by the ground ball today we
always think of strikeouts he does have
four but two ground ball double plays
turn overall he's had
seven outs via the ground ball tonight
usually that's something he doesn't get
light up but so far so good as far as
shoei ohtani pitching to contact getting
deeper in the game
oh tony's gone past five innings only
three times this year three of his nine
starts his longest a seven inning start
at houston in mid-may
out there for the sixth after a lot of
running in the bottom of the fifth
this is going to be a real big inning
for shohei ohtani mentioned the running
three times on the move
and here he is going into the sixth
inning to keep trying to keep those legs
strong and he's at the top of the order
especially a guy that we've mentioned
before
bobby grossman who's had a lot of
success
against the angels in his career i'm
thinking he's up there swinging first
pitch even though he's patient this
might be the at-bat where he's ready to
swing early in the count against ohtani
maybe get a ball he he likes and drive
it
involving no strikes accounts of
grossman top of the order in the tigers
sixth so far for the tigers
a couple of micro rallies
they had two runners aboard with nobody
out in the fourth their best opportunity
to score
but then a fly ball and a double play
finished him off rather quickly two
balls and no strikes
you know we talk about this often rajay
the fact that pitchers aren't really
allowed an opportunity to go deep into
lineups and deep into games anymore and
how third time through the results get
worse for pitchers however for ohtani
when facing the lineup for the third
time opponents are only four for 27 this
year
wow all four hits are only singles
wow that's that's pretty impressive
because i know as you get as you get to
see the pitcher's release point
for the third time in the ball game
that's where you actually start to feel
real comfortable
especially if you if you if you have a
knock already
under your belt man you're you're
looking for two or three knocks by that
time
hopefully if you're feeling good
angel's bullpen yet to get busy behind
ohtani but tyler alexander is up for the
tigers
we'll see which manager is the first to
blink into its bullpen tonight
3-1 to grossman
that's just a good pitch 3-1
backdoor curveball
not really looking for that that's not
the pitch you want that's not the pitch
you're going to look to drive right
there 3-1 pitch
but he's also looking to get on base
and grossman takes a 3-2 pitch into
right
and that's ohtani's first out of the
inning
a new to the mlb game of the week for
the 2021 season is the youtube player of
the game where fans watching on mobile
devices and computers can vote for which
player will receive the trophy during
the post game show
stay tuned for the player of the game
polling options
coming up later on tonight
i hereby submit shohei ohtani is an
official candidate
newsflash he's speaking he's been
waiting
he's been pretty good
one gun for jonathan scope who struck
out twice in the game tonight
you know for folks watching the angels
for the first time tonight
gooby the fact that ohtani's presence
has actually changed policy
in that they use a six-man rotation
it speaks volumes about how important he
is when the other five guys have to
adjust to different days off
to accommodate one man it tells you how
important that one man is
and they've all accepted that also i
mean they've all said you know every
time i've talked to any starter because
usually we're all about routine starting
pitchers you have your bullpen session
in between starts every five days they
all said the same thing we get to go an
extra day we get the workout we get to
maybe potentially get a little deeper in
the game and throw more pitches with
shohei ohtani's presence because he's
been the ace of the staff when he's been
out there on the mound
2-1
oh man
well hit into left field upton can only
watch and that one is gone
a hangar that jonathan scope crushes to
make it a one-run game
jonathan has been on the tear late and
that's what he does with mistakes
so far in this inning he's tried to get
back into counts show hey throwing his
slide remember even against grossman
twice to get back in the count through
his slider then he got the fly out with
a slide it's a backup type slider that
hanging one and stays in middle plate
and roger you know it's a hitter you
don't miss those pitches that's one of
those cement mixers that go right to the
barrel of the bat scope without crushing
the baseball those are the pitches you
where you're licking your child oh i
seen it up i can't wait till this thing
comes down
jonathan scopes seventh homer in his
last 14 games he is on an absolute tear
and now it's jammer candelario and i
would imagine that that would get the
angels bullpen busy here in the sixth
inning
far no movement down to the bullpen
that's the first home run that show has
allowed on a secondary pitch this year
all home runs all four have been on his
fastball but that one on a slider
that could be just paying attention
watching the game and seeing how many
curveballs he's been throwing lately
through
couple to
the hitter right before him
had some success you might feel okay i
can try it again
you know one thing to keep an eye on he
hasn't thrown a lot of splitters
of late that was a 98 mile an hour
fastball that he was late on
using with two strikes shohei goes to a
splitter
for a swing and miss
yeah he has thrown in his 72 pitches a
total of just nine splitters
and there's one that's bounced to the
right side ohtani picks it up
[Applause]
dance moves
i'm just going to say now we can dance
we were wondering we were doing that bo
knows stuff earlier anybody talking
about shohei knows he could do
everything and trot was joking about
that before
shohei showing a dance move gets that
ball and still steps on the base before
there's a valeria was able
[Applause]
you just cannot take your eyes off this
guy
everything he does is is better and more
fun to watch
than with anybody else in the league
and he's got the two-step dance going
and he could dance
two gone for miguel cabrera
winning without his split i'm just going
to guess and uh
and ask our statistician on youtube
tonight the great matt baker
this has to be
his lowest split finger fastball count
in any start this year
yeah in every game i've seen him that's
the pitch he goes to he's about
overall in the season about 22 23
usage of a splitter harry starts cabrera
with a slider then he threw him a
curveball
two balls in a strike to count to
cabrera
perhaps he has a better feel for his
curveball this game he
he's already hit one batter with the
splitter maybe he's not feeling as
comfortable with the with the
in splitter i think miggy was the guy
that he hit with a splitter earlier in
the game
yeah that might have been that's
i think it might have been the last one
i've seen from least effective or not it
wasn't effective the one he actually
threw
i imagine he's got to go right back with
a slider or is he trying to challenge a
fastball away
it's a slider
and it's five strikeouts for otani
tigers do get on the board however it's
a 2-1 game entering the bottom of the
sixth inning tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
high fly ball to the corner it goes into
deep right field ohtani
[Applause]
oh my
he
oh my goodness oh my goodness
what can't he do
showtime all the time that's a 94 mile
an hour fastball
don't try to sneak a fastball in against
shohei ohtani sixth career home run
against cleveland
they were up there trying to do as much
damage as they could there's damage
right there
way
way side
of where that land
just like that two nothing angels that
just kind of fell into his back right
there and he had to say well too
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now after matt manning got
his first career strikeout in the second
to end the inning
miguel cabrera accidentally threw the
ball to a fan in the crowd not realizing
the significance of that ball but the
whole team ended up coming out of the
dugout they were able to track the fan
down and trade a new baseball with that
fan they got it back and then mickey
kind of gave me that smile and an
whoopsie shrug but all is good in the
world now oh man
problem avoided i i'm glad that the that
the guys all you know championed his
cause and i'm also glad that the very
kind fan understood that that was
something very important oh absolutely
that would is what you would call maybe
a rookie making that kind of mistake but
those are those are kind of things that
your teammates
obviously they they're recognizing
they're paying attention they're
sticking up they want they want that
ball that's that's that's something that
you're going to cherish that's going to
keep with you for the wreck you like
left-hander tyler alexander takes over
and he'll face jared walsh kurt suzuki
and keon wong alexander making his 19th
appearance of the year tonight he's made
some starts this year
[Applause]
eva that's a pretty good fastball
either that was a mistake 88 92
002 to walsh
[Applause]
walsh is putting together a nice little
season here
he's a legitimate all-star candidate
this year
he's been one of the angels biggest
power sources
look at that they're in the shift and
the tigers haven't played perfectly
yes
we're gonna get you into another poll
question here as we compare
two hall of famers a future hall of
famer that's still active in a new
uniform and a future hall of famer
that's been in the same uniform for a
long time in miguel cabrera
eight mvps combined
and we'll ask you the completely unfair
question
which is the most impressive offensive
player
all of them will be in cooperstown
you want to tackle that one roger well i
was thinking which is the which is the
most impressive player for the first 10
years
okay first 10 years of his career yeah
first 10 years and if if i'm looking at
that
i'm out of those
no i gotta go with pujols i think i
think i gotta go with pujols
i mean that is just an entirely unfair
question
which one of those guys would you least
want to face yeah
oh yeah
i i faced the big hurt too many times i
was on the scoreboard in chicago for the
longest home run i think it was 474 for
an entire season so frank seriously put
the big hurt against one of my sliders
but i got to go with albert pohl it's
just because that the overall numbers as
far as top five all-time in doubles and
home runs albert sits alone as far as
those categories and rbi and mvps and
world series championship gold gloves
albert is that guy and albert albert hit
the ground running like from day one he
was great
kurt suzuki sends a flare out to right
field that's going to drop in a fang an
ugly thang for a base hit
[Applause]
well sometimes when you swing that ball
swing that bat
you'll find yourself on first base
[Applause]
with a ball like that phil mickelson
will be real proud of that sand wedge
that was a great sand wedge and checked
up too
look at that
that's that's an easy give me pot after
that chip shot please repair your divots
[Applause]
you know joe madden has a a saying
around the angels as we'll have a pinch
hitter here for kian wong this is phil
gosling
there's a saying around the angels this
year play like it's 1985.
roger it feels like it's 1985 from where
we are in the studio because of the wave
going around the ballpark
gooby this this i mean fans are loving
the fact that they're back tonight and
everybody is out there letting it eat
yeah they're all having a good old time
they they're all back at the ballpark
here everyone doing the wave
i'll tell you it's a great feeling to
see i just saw so many smiles on
people's faces coming into the stadium
that didn't get a chance to before with
that limited capacity
sends a drive out to center field that's
going to hang for cameron
and as a player you actually look for
those things you know you know what's
coming the wave
is coming it's usually going the same
direction
mostly there was one there was one time
though
that i saw
we were in milwaukee where the wave went
one way the crowd stopped it and turned
the other way i've never seen it since
and they actually slowed it down did
like the matrix kind of thing and
sped it up it was it was pretty it was
pretty it was pretty cool it was pretty
cool if any place is capable of doing
that it's milwaukee milwaukee they were
out there before we got to the ballpark
okay
camping outside having a good time i
don't know how many beers they've had
before we got to the ballpark
on a day game yeah a lot is the answer
[Applause]
a runner aboard with two god for juan
lagares
it sounds like a montreal crowd gooby
you know in montreal they would like ooh
and ah over foul balls yes
that's what it sounds like it sounds
like a bunch of folks that haven't been
to a baseball game in a long time which
is exactly what it is
exactly anytime a fan makes a play on a
foul ball it's like everyone's ready to
give them a standing ovation
still owen two to two
player it must have been so hard last
year playing without fans you know that
roger david sometimes as a hitter you
get energized by the crowd it's got had
it been i know trouty talked about it
earlier and i talked to him during the
offseason he said it was the most
difficult thing to play
baseball without fans there whether they
were for you or against you
exactly especially trout you know he had
fans all his career you know they're
always watching wanting to watch him
but like
it it kind of reminded me of the minor
leagues ballparks those stadiums
especially on those rain delays or those
those games where it was raining were
very few
fans in the in the stands
tony watson will be the new pitcher
entering for ohtani as we go to the
seventh in a one-run game
the big red hats
the big
a these make angel stadium feel like a
ballpark
but you
you make angel stadium feel more like
home
as the song goes take me out to the ball
game
take me out with the crowd
baseball is meant to be enjoyed with a
crowd
after a year of waiting
we're excited to open up the doors to
full capacity on june 17th
we look forward to being fully together
once again angel fans
welcome back
bienvenidoso
welcome back
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hey push your favorite players to the
top this summer with the 2021 google mlb
all-star ballot vote daily at mlb.com
vote and on google by searching mlb
all-star vote to send them to colorado
how about the leading vote getters in
the american league by position
mike trout with over 700 000 votes
leading all outfielders vlad guerrero jr
leading all american leaguers
shohei ohtani leading at dh
so some changes defensively for the
angels as phil gosling takes over
at third base for kee and wong
and a new pitcher as well looking to
bounce back from a really rough outing a
day ago the veteran left-hander tony
watson
you know those guys always pulling out
that car to see where they're supposed
to stand it's like
[Applause]
joe madden putting watson right back out
there after a rough outing yesterday
gooby in which he allowed five hits and
walked to batter did not record an out
yesterday
and that's one thing about joe madden
that's why players love playing for him
email for a tough outing like that for
tony watson he's going to put him right
back in the game as quick as possible
nico goodroom pinch hitting and sending
a ball off the wall in right center
field
the tigers have the time to run in
scoring position you think that got out
they might review that one
yeah because unless it's off the glove i
think that might have got above the line
[Music]
see here better angle but fastball just
got a lot of the plate
and 92 mile an hour fastball oh no
no that is below it just below it
[Applause]
did not take the pinch hitter long nico
goodram
[Applause]
he didn't try to pull that ball he
didn't try to pull that ball he kind of
inside out that
hit the inside part of that ball and
drove it to right center
[Applause]
here's eric haas now over two so far
tonight ohtani went six struck out five
and the really unusual part of the start
for ohtani tonight is we kind of put a
bow on it is that he threw a career-high
32 sliders tonight
[Applause]
he was very active on the mound at one
point
dies four throws to first base had a
cover for a first base on a slow roll in
his way tried to steal the bags a couple
times when he was on the bases too so
maybe joe madden at this point felt all
right i got the most out of my get
especially with the limited feel for his
splitter tonight and going back to the
bullpen
[Applause]
mike myers up in the bullpen
joe madden's going to give
watson a little opportunity here to get
it back together as haas bounces it to
shortstop
fletcher's got it goodroom's got to stay
at second base
yeah that's a huge out not only a lot of
times when you make it out you want to
productive out a few of the tigers but
he hits that one to short and keeps
goodr second base
ohtani went under the fanduel posted
strikeout total tonight of seven and a
half
cast with a little plus money
here's akil badu now with a runner at
second and one gone
badou had two hits against ohtani
tonight
two hits for badou two for candelario
and a homer for scope
gotta feel gotta feel good if you're
about to do about about that about that
showing you know but obviously they're
in in a position he's he's got an
opportunity right here to
tie the ball game with the hit
there goes the runner
throw down to third is not in time
nico goodram steals third and the time
runs in scoring position 90 feet away
now with one gun
he gotta go
he's gonna try to steal third
[Applause]
a huge jump no chance at all for zoo
gets this is a good play by godzilla to
keep it in front of him on the low throw
but you knew he was going to try to
steal after the out
did not allow him to advance
you knew he was going to try to steal
and he just timed it and timed it
perfectly to seal the base that was just
stolen beast only been caught once
that was just a great opportunity great
time to steal got this pitcher
left hand uh
oh and now they've got good room hung up
watson
back to suzuki
this is awkward this is awkward
walsh is involved now
he's hired fletcher
does he get him he does uh
that was about
four too many throws oh yeah
i think he should have just kept the
oh textbook like aj hincher is going to
look and make sure he applied the tag
well credit but do on the back end of
this
getting all the third yeah
oh that was wild
yeah ideally as a pitcher you feel this
ball
and you run
the base runner back to third and get
rid of as quick as possible it was a low
throw
and a lot of things went wrong on that
one the engine has been pretty decent as
far as the fundamentals but this was not
fundamentally done well you got to give
good
you know kudos for that base running to
be able to get in that long enough where
you got them to go all the way over to
third base but that wasn't textbook as
far as making sure he stayed at first
base now you still have a man to third
you have that wild pitch still in order
to score a run
[Applause]
so it's a fielder's choice play score to
badou that he gets all the way to third
base on very wisely advancing in front
of all the histrionics between
third and the plate
and now willy castro
that's a lot of excitement for one play
the excitement's a good
that's one way to put it i as that was
happening in real time i heard i heard
the benny hill theme song in my brain
yakity sacks
i was hoping you would tell us you're
the one at the ballpark
i'm guessing they're gonna have to go to
replay
you know i can only count to three so
that went beyond that one
a ball to strike to count to willy
castro
switch hitting second baseman tonight
he stays in there from the right side as
he was or actually switches around about
from the right side
[Music]
watson can't get the call two balls in a
strike you heard a fan cat call come on
jeremy jeremy riggs
is the
umpire tonight calling balls and strikes
he is a
a triple a call up on fire this is just
his 13th plate assignment in the big
leagues he's been pretty good tonight
though i got to give him credit
we haven't said his name yet and usually
for an umpire that represents the
greatest of compliments
[Applause]
two balls and two strikes with two out
time run at third
[Applause]
the chopper red heaphouse to retire the
side
and an opportunity for the tigers that
goes away
[Music]
and there goes the michigan state and
all of tigerdom
upstairs two to nothing tigers in the
first inning there's a base hit thurman
is just about done three nothing detroit
here comes dick williams
wiggins cuts the line drive left center
field in for a base hit rounding third
heading home
and the game is tied three to three one
out in the seventh
four to three detroit
and he lines it to flat back goes
martinez gone
gosh he's saying i can get him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
lead it eight to four in the eighth
inning
wings of this a fly ball to left here
comes herndon he's here he's got it the
tigers are the champions of 1984.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it is the 26 year old two-way wonder
show hey otani to make his 10th starting
assignment of the year we are underway
in anaheim but dues on his way to third
in time
3-2 pitch
you just cannot take your eyes off this
guy everything he does
still a one-run game at angel stadium in
anaheim california we welcome you back
with mark gouveza and making his
broadcast debut former tiger rodger
davis matt baskerjian with you and a
couple of changes as nico goodrum stays
in the ball game
and
time to break out the funk kyle
funkhouser on the mound for the tigers
[Applause]
her power fastball 94-97 will throw a
slider and a change-up
funkhouser last pitched on monday
a scoreless two-thirds of an inning
against the royals walked a batter
struck out another
he too has made a start this year
and luis renjifo will lead things off
for the angels looking to pad their one
run lead
sharply hit right back up the middle
amazing ball
also get to that ball
do you see the difference in how
grossman attacked that ball the right
field attacked that ball as opposed to
in the early endings when the angels got
their runs
he uh
he aggressively got to that ball quick
so he could shut down that runner
from going to second because he doesn't
shut down until
the outfielder feels that ball and
throws it a second
that's one thing yeah he's he's a really
good base runner
[Applause]
he's got that brian goodwin beard coming
in nice too
the tigers in sensing a hit-and-run with
fletcher at the plate
[Applause]
i'm amazed how guys can wear these big
chains and
it's just not it seems like it don't
affect them i don't i don't like getting
hit in the mouth with all that change
fletcher's bunting
funkhouser to second oh and it's
mishandled by castro
well they had renjifo by a step and a
half
i think you got to hang the error on the
infielder there gooby yeah
oh yes i mean you know
funkhouser did a real nice job of
getting that baseball quickly turns his
body
in a good quick throw it's gonna look
like he was thinking quick on the double
play on the transfer said they're just
getting that out at second base to keep
a double play in order instead there's
no outs you're not going to turn a
double play on that one so you just want
to make that play at second you almost
try to be a first baseman stretch get to
the bag and get the force out yeah i
think that's the challenge with being a
utility guy and not really having a a
set position you're not playing her all
the time you're not you're not you're
not doing it all the time you know
you're now for one one game then you're
in the field and
one of the great guys that i saw do that
well was uh i thought uh ben ben zobrist
did a good job at that you know being
able to be an outfielder
and an infielder and and
be able to make the plays those routine
plays those that play has to be made
though right there
it was nico goodwin you're facing a guy
like
like up in there he wants to do some
damage against a team and trade it
to the angels of the really productive
years with the tigers for justin up and
now a chance
to add on runs here late for the angels
almost 60 homers
in upton's two-year stay as a tiger he
was an all-star there in 2017 the most
recent of his four all-star appearances
and just to correct myself that was nico
goodram handling the throw at second
base not castro
big opportunity here for the angels to
add on
just a one run lead in the seventh
and it's two balls in the strike
great returns for the angels once upton
has been installed as the lead-off
hitter
[Music]
they're definitely definitely going to
take a look at that one i think they got
him at first base
miguel cabrera was able to reach out and
get to that baseball right away he was
saying he thought he got him i think
they'll take a shot at this one
yes and aj hinch is going to call for
the challenge
[Applause]
this is a great play castro came in on
this one and got a lot on that bare hand
throw
up and runs well we'd always talk about
his power but he could run that's a
great play
[Music]
yeah the throw was there did did the
foot come off though
we're gonna take another couple of looks
at this
[Music]
i think you might have got him right
there
[Music]
well regardless jose iglesias is going
to pinch it next
he'll either do so with one out or with
the bases loaded and nobody gone
[Music]
oh boy
i don't know it's much closer than we
thought
yeah i mean yeah you i thought he was he
got him but he's not on the bag there
let's see if he gets the foot down
wow yeah you're right wow
so like the angle i had right away i
think you know i know the baseball beat
him there but for some reason cabrera
didn't have his foot on the base i think
because it was such a great play at
short
call stands bases are loaded with nobody
out
that's going to be an infield single for
justin upton
[Music]
this game seems like it's coming down to
those little things
[Music]
making a difference making the plays
on defense
that you should make
[Applause]
oh boy this has
turned into a sticky spot for the tigers
as pitching coach chris federer is out
for a conversation they've got daniel
norris up in the bullpen
[Music]
a quick reminder this copyrighted
telecast is presented by the authority
of the office of the commissioner and
may not be reproduced or retransmitted
in any form the accounts and
descriptions of this game may not be
disseminated without expressed written
consent
jose iglesias is the pinch hitter a
non-starter getting a scheduled day off
his feet
he picks on the first pitch and drives
it into left field gren heapo scores
fletcher is held at third and it's three
to one angels
yeah that's not unusual for iglesias to
be ready
on the first pitch
and he lines that one with the infield
in picking up an rbi he has been a very
good run producer for joe madden this
year there was talk about him in spring
training moving him up into batting
order you've seen him already hit three
and four this one he gets a chance at a
fastball and he drives it right away and
able to get that through that drone in
infield for an rbi single for iglesias
being ready to hit once you get it up
there
especially with man in the scoring
position
one on one off now a two-run lead for
the angels and taylor ward with the
bases loaded 0 for three tonight so far
ward swings and sends a drive to left
field that one's got a chance
i didn't i didn't realize he hit that
ball that far
it didn't look
he's being rewarded putting up that
number three spot in the lineup coming
in the game guys 424 slugging percentage
for taylor ward if you go up a chance to
talk to him you can see he is super
strong very aggressive in the past he
would let that first pitch go by but
he's been aggressive swinging early and
boy did he did the damage swinging
around that with a grand slam
taylor ward's first career hit with the
bases loaded
is a grand slam that has blown this one
wide open
two balls and no strikes to walsh
boy that leverage he created and he
crushed that baseball it's a slider one
of those back up cement mixers right
over the plate trying to get ahead of
the count pinnable right down the heart
of the plate at 88.
no push to hit
oh challenge fastball guys i had a
chance to
talk to taylor before the game he had an
infielder's glow his outfielder's glove
and he also i said where's your
catcher's minute and all of a sudden he
pulled it from behind his back he had
his catchers mid also
he doesn't care where joe maddo puts him
defensively
he just wants to swing the bat and he
did on that one bad about for sure
both of the angels grand slams have come
at home this year justin upton hit one
in mid-april
at angel stadium against the twins
ward tonight and the damage by the way
gooby
coming on back to back pitches i mean
iglesias up there hacking bases loaded
first pitch single ward next pitch
slam that's one thing as a hey you know
what
going up
going up there you got to be ready you
got to be ready to hit
and ready ready to hit that first pitch
because they they want to get ahead they
want to get ahead the pitchers want to
get ahead and the hitchers you got to be
ready to hit that pitch
yeah joe maddon says he wants to play
like 1985 you've referenced that early
matt you know that everyone was
aggressive they're not working about
working counts in 1985 they're looking
for their best pitch to hit that first
pitch may be your best hit iglesias
lines a single
taylor ward
drives a slider out on the first pitch
so five runs driven in on just two
pitches being aggressive on the first
pitch
batting averages on those first pitch is
a lot higher too
not sure what they are but i i know
that those are usually higher numbers
and walsh swings and misses
that is the first out of the inning
yeah roger
[Applause]
yeah roger i was going to answer that as
a hitter and i know as a pitcher that
first pitch is so important to be able
to throw a strike i would think as a
hitter i'd be at more apt to be
aggressive on the first pitch with the
bases loaded because you got a pitcher
trying to throw a strike so be ready to
attack it oh absolutely you definitely
have to be ready to hit that pitch
i mean
especially with men men in scoring
position the pitchers really when when
you're going up there as a as a as a
hitter
you think the pitcher's in trouble not
the hitter
he's in trouble the bases are loaded men
are out there he's got he's got to come
to the zone
right so
you got to go up there
as a hitter
being
very ready to hit
[Applause]
kurt suzuki now with one away to your
point roger
the major league batting average on the
first pitch this year is 3.39
wow
when the pitcher gets ahead 0-1 it drops
to 190.
so yeah get up there and hack oh-oh
right
i love count jumpers
now the difference is you know a guy
pops up on the first pitch and everybody
says ah what are you swinging at the
first pitch for it's a shot back up the
middle for suzuki a basement
did you notice how he felt at the ball
this time he really attacked that ball
he learned he learned his lesson from
the previous innings he
he's he's making the adjustment and
that's what it's about
[Applause]
maybe a couple innings too late but
that's that's what it's about
young young you have the younger
outfielders out there
yeah there's going to be pitching change
here
as
funkhouser is removed
[Applause]
and the tigers will go back to the
bullpen
7-1 angels we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
so mark figrich is the man people have
come to see tonight we were curious
coming to the ballpark who the hell is
this crazy guy you know
you'll see him mumble a couple of words
to the ball he was an oddity a real
oddity nobody ever did what fidridge did
look at him talking to that ball what
pitcher ever
the guy could pitch all this other stuff
wouldn't have mattered if he was getting
his brains beat in another easy inning
for the young right-hander mark federer
as the ninth inning began fidrich and
the tigers had a five-to-one lead
and the fans are standing
i've seen a lot of ball games played and
i've caught a few i don't think i've
ever seen a pitcher this keyed up the
fans ready to explode here's your pitch
ground ball should be the ball game
it's over
and the tigers act like fiddler has just
won the seventh game of the world series
he has
he's won seven in a row he is some kind
of unbelievable
young mark coogles
[Music]
[Music]
here behind the scenes conversations
with all stars and mvps on mlb's new
player to player podcast the biggs with
xavier scruggs
search the bigs on apple podcast spotify
or wherever you listen
tigers single game tickets for all
tigers home games july through september
go on sale tomorrow at 10 a.m don't miss
the red sox rangers blue jays and more
go to tigers.com
tickets
[Applause]
[Music]
the tigers are on their
second pitcher of the inning
it'll be buck farmer to work here with
one out one on
and five runs in
in the bottom of the seventh
[Applause]
buck farmer working his way back to the
big leagues
called up from aaa toledo
prior to sunday series finale against
the white sox this is the second
appearance on the big league roster
[Applause]
guy with plenty of starters experience
over his tigers career
[Applause]
he's just trying to finish off what has
been a really troubling inning for
detroit in the bottom of the seventh
three balls in those strikes the counts
of phil gosling
yeah threw him a 2-0 change-up fastball
still pretty good one for farmer it's 92
to 98 i'll throw a curveball but
back-to-back change-ups
3-0
[Applause]
this narrative turned
the tigers had the tying run at third
base with less than two out in the top
of the inner
and now they find themselves down by six
3-1 to gosling sent out to right center
field and that's in for a now
and that's that separator that separates
the teams that are that are winning in
in the detroit tigers right now
just making just doing those being able
to do those little things
get to balls keep guys from getting
extra bases not giving an extra 90 feet
and not allowing
you know the team to take advantage of
of really mental mistakes overthrowing
cut off men
giving extra bases but those things you
can
avoid
as a position player as a defense these
things can be avoidable um just playing
ahead
playing the head of game
and and just knowing ahead of time what
you're going to do with the baseball
when the ball is hit to you
here's juan lagar as the ninth angel to
bat in the inning
[Applause]
there's some wild games going on around
major league baseball as we speak
the reds and padres in san diego
that was a two-nothing lead for san
diego going to the top of the night the
red score four
and the padres have scored two in the
bottom of the inning to tie it
and eric hosmer two-run homer
the inning ending double play
plenty of angels damage however
including taylor ward's first career
grand slam
[Applause]
seven to one angels
baseball is a hard game
you know i give credit to the hitters of
course but at the same time when i step
on that mound and you're facing me you
know
i'm going to treat you like i treat
anybody else
you know i don't care how big you are i
don't care how strong you are i don't
care how big the name
i'm gonna come at you with my best stuff
and if you uh if you get a hit i'm gonna
tip my cap to you but you know i'm gonna
really come at you and as long as you're
you have a bat and you're in the box i'm
going to come at you and i'm going to be
competitive
swinging i miss a fastball knight
to the count
sinking fastball outside corner that's
strike three this whole big league
experience um has been a great it's been
super fun it's been a great atmosphere
and it's been a lot of learning you know
there's a lot of parts of the game that
i
missed out from two years of rehab
that i'm starting to learn now and
luckily i have a lot of veteran guys
here who have
taken me in and they've you know helped
me out so much you know they tell me
what they see they tell me what they
don't like they tell me what they like
and you know i need that you know you
need criticism you need uh you need guys
to really
come to you and kind of tell you what
they think and kind of you build off
that
[Music]
access exclusive behind the scenes
content on the detroit tigers youtube
channel visit youtube.com
tigers to follow the team today
[Music]
hey we've got the results from our most
recent youtube poll
[Music]
which of these hall of fame caller
players two were already there and it's
uh close between maggie and albert
pujols but albert wins by a nose
[Applause]
i mean how could you go wrong with any
one of those four guys really what's
your favorite pizza topping right it's
like one of those
mike myers is the new pitcher on the
mound for the angels and he inherits a
six-run lead
[Applause]
[Applause]
i always love when albert pulse when
he's with the angels get the first base
with miguel cabrera was there the
conversations they would have and i'm
sitting there thinking hey there's a
there's a thousand home runs combined
plus
when those two were having a
conversation at first base and they were
always smiling and very similar as far
as their approach hitting line drives
the other way but still could turn and
hit a ball a long way to left but very
difficult very difficult outs even if
you're a right-handed pitcher or
left-handed pitcher with miguel cabrera
and alberts
two one to dash cameron is grounded back
up the middle base hit
a google cloud is helping to power hey
cameron is powering himself into second
base
all right
using that speed
how much of that ball that he kind of
loafed on in center field was in his
brain right there when he decided to go
exactly he's thinking oh you want to do
that to me or i'ma get you back right
here
[Applause]
a lot of that a lot of that was just his
yes he turned it on late you see he
turned it on late taking advantage of
them just not being able to get to the
ball
fast enough
cameron in scoring position now for
robbie grossman who's hitless with a
walk tonight
of course right there
you definitely you have to be safe you
cannot get thrown out right there
trying to stretch a single into a double
down by six runs
yeah good point
you better you better be right
balling a strikeout count
now
366 with runners in scoring position i
mean he's been very very consistent
center that two-year deal with the
tigers
giving that better influence in the
lineup but also very productive on both
sides of the plate
[Applause]
oh yeah
into center field
cameron's going to score without a play
at the plate one of those runs comes
right back
[Applause]
a 7-2 ball game
[Applause]
yeah the one guy you don't want to face
with running position
that's a trying to go back door cutter
and he just stayed right with it that's
a beautiful swing by grossman picking up
an rbi on that single left center
[Applause]
that's a ball that should just go right
into second base you don't want to risk
giving
the batted runner
a chance to go to second base
there's jonathan scope now he is homer
tonight
the angels do have to find six more outs
tonight
and it's a
angels
bullpen
with a 4.84 era that is in the bottom
third of the
of the big leagues of all major league
teams
one and one
[Applause]
scope's homer means he's hit safely in
20 of his last 24
and again after the rough start he got
off to it's been a great rebound that's
into the opposite field and that's
trouble that's down in front of ward
that's three straight knocks yielded by
mike myers
and that's right away the bullpen has
been
an issue especially holding late leads
and three at bats in a row hitting the
ball the other way that's what you got
to try to do especially with a pitcher
there's a lot of cut fast balls and
sliders and that's exactly what the
tigers have done in this inning and all
of a sudden they're putting some
pressure right away
on the bullpen for the angels
good for scope getting another hit you
know in april if you just saw his
batting average he wouldn't think he'd
be in this position right now
come june
but he has
battled he has
obviously found his swing he's found his
groove and
he's hitting balls where the defense
can't make plays on
in the seats
two bullpens here head to head that have
had a hard time finishing games
from the looks at it
the tigers are not out of this
well the angels sure don't think so
because they've got their closer up
[Applause]
here's jamer candelario now he's got a
couple singles tonight
that answer back inning is such an
important thing
you talk about it a lot on the air jay
give up a crooked number you chip away
and get some of it back immediately
that's a big deal emotionally if nothing
else oh absolutely
that's that's that competing that's that
battling back we're not giving in
we're not we're not just going to roll
over on you
we're going to fight back and we're
going to
try to get some
get some guys on base any anyway now
kendall is looking at a 2-0
looking to drive something here
takes a strike on the corner 2-1
i don't think joe madden is going to
wait long here today with uh mike myers
either rice iglesias one time already
this year
a six out save came in with the bases
loaded and no outs and was able to
preserve a victory
it's been a long time between postseason
appearances for both of these teams and
for the angels
since their last postseason appearance
in 2015
they qualified for the postseason the
previous year to clarify
their safe percentage is among the worst
in baseball
i think i was part of that detroit
tigers team the last time they went to
the playoffs in 2014
and that was a team team that was a lot
of a lot of a lot of big name players on
that no doubt
three balls and two strikes
miguel cabrera waiting on deck payoff
pitch
ball four and that loads the bases
[Applause]
and it loads the bases in front of a
future hall of famer we talked about
miguel cabrera the 11 time all-star
earlier won the triple crown in 2012
one of his mvp years and he's got a
couple of milestones within his sights
as well
eight homers away from 500.
he's gonna come back and think about it
as joe madden is going to make a
pitching change here
it'll be reisel iglesias in the eighth
with the bases loaded and nobody out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't miss a minute of exciting angels
action head to the angels youtube page
to catch big moments interviews from
players and alumni and more visit
youtube.com
angels and subscribe to the channel
today
well ryzel iglesias will be the new
pitcher for the angels
interesting choice here
last appeared on june 12th over the
weekend in arizona
pittston inning and allowed a run to
earn his 11th save of the year but
here's why you might have some optimism
if you're a tigers fan
not only are the bases loaded with
nobody out
but reichsel iglesias has allowed more
homers than anybody in baseball
after the seventh inning this year
what's it uh what's the odds he's doing
uh first pitch slider right here
you tell me what do you think
i think it's pretty good
looking for that ground ball
i would agree
no fastball comes right after cabrera
who struck out on three fastballs
against ohtani back in the first
[Applause]
some serious numbers with the bases
loaded the glaciers will throw a
fastball 96-98 he has a great change-up
and a wipeout slider
his miss rate against the slider is 55
this year that's a top ten figure among
all relievers in baseball
[Applause]
this is a similar situation as to the
one iglesias entered back on june 4th
against the mariners
base has loaded nobody out in the eighth
and iglesias and the angels survived
that
that was a 3-2 lead he's got a little
bit more room to work with here tonight
[Applause]
falling two strikes to cabrera
yeah he went drop down slider
and then with that arm angle again and
miggy was thinking he's dropping down
with a slider this time he ran a
fastball that starts on the outside part
of the plane and then runs in and
catches the corner at 97. so that's able
to throw two different pitches from that
same arm angle gets one of the all-time
great hitters looking on a fastball i
mean that's that's el duque type stuff
right there gooby
yeah
and he'll throw his change up even from
that arm angle too that's going to be
about 87.88
so now nico goodroom starting with a 97
mile an hour fastball
goodrum doubled to open the seventh
and
then was caught between
holmen third on a play that went one
five two six three six five
eight six seven five three oh nine
we talked we talked about that
pitch we just talked about that pitch
and how what batters hit on that and
you see a couple guys just take
the first two pitch the first pitch
of their bats
the first fastball
that's a great change out from iglesias
so he's got a real good arm angle good
arm action with it
[Applause]
oh and two to goodram base is still
loaded with one god
grossman scope and candelario aboard
with a run in
[Applause]
into right field down in front of ward
it's going to score one as grossman
crosses the plate
a 7-3 angels lead
you know what i almost credit grossman
for that when he pretended he was going
to come home glacia steps off and runs
toward him he has him in an o2 count and
then he makes a mistake in the middle of
the plate grossman distracted him enough
and goodwill made him pay for that with
an rbi single
[Applause]
change up middle of the plate but down
sweet spot for a left-handed swing
good one making him an impact swing in
the back
twice in the game
[Applause]
strike one to eric haas
this guy has the potential to tie this
ball game right here he definitely has
the power
[Applause]
he's got eight home runs in about
101 at bats
haas is the tying run with the bases
loaded
and again iglesias drops down to
style for the slider
one of the biggest problems for the
angels especially out of the bullpen has
been the amount of hits they've given up
even their starting staff and they've
been ahead of the count 02 this year
more of the plate than they want to
throw on that pitch instead of trying to
get you notice rajay is a hitter you
love to see a pitcher trying to get you
out in the on the plate oh absolutely
and this right here this number is going
to get another another
iglesia is just able to get there for
the out but yes an additional run does
score as scope crosses the plate
[Applause]
and the tigers have chipped away for
three here in the eighth
another hit right here
you got a whole
another ball game
and he was late covered that was a
pretty good play by walsh's pitchers
late covering the bag he had to make
sure he let him as he got towards the
base he threw that a little bit harder
than he wanted to because iglesia was
late getting off the mound and the angle
he took straight at the bag
was a difficult one to catch and tag the
bag
[Applause]
here's a keel badoon now representing
the tying run
[Applause]
what is going on there's been some wonky
moments here
the throwback from suzuki was
was offline and
iglesias had to hop off the mound to
gather it in
[Applause]
i mean that's heads up by iglesias you
know runner at third base
and knowing how aggressive the tigers
run the bases
he was on that quickly the 0-1
so the throw
back to the pitcher actually hit the bat
of akil badou
yeah it means it's a dead ball it's a
dead ball yeah
oh got it okay we didn't see that in
real time
yes
close one
two balls in a strike
by duprint feeling pretty good today
got two for three got a chance right
here to
help his ball club
chop it at second base for red hippo
that's actually fletcher fletcher at
second base who makes that play
three however come right back in the
angels half of the eighth
seven four angels
three two pitch
[Applause]
tram has always been a detroit tiger
from day one
i never heard one conversation with tram
and even mentioned about going to
another team that's where we grew up
that's where we were going to play
our career and i'm sure some other teams
would have loved to have you know
trammell whitaker playing second and
short form
but we love we love playing with the
detroit tiger baseball organization
he spent 20 years as detroit's shortstop
he now joins the baseball hall of fame
class of 2018
alan trammell i'm just as happy as he is
truthfully we've always said he deserved
to be in the hall of fame he played hard
to deserve it and
it's as he would say
it's finally been accomplished
[Music]
bottom of the eighth inning a reminder
that google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball and
we'll use it to take another look at
taylor ward's big first career grand
slam mark bubazzo
yeah he stayed back and he's been
driving the ball he's been aggressive i
mean you look at his numbers on first
pitch and he's attacking that one he's
been very good a little bit too patient
back in the day when he first came up
trying to lift the ball out now it's
more on the line they got backspin to be
able to get that one over the left
center field wall for grand slam first
of his career
luis renjifo was the man that started
the five run rally with the leadoff
single in the seventh he'll open the
eighth
as buck farmer continues renjifo
fletcher and upton
[Applause]
from the left side for the first time in
this game
amazing impact in this game for red
heapho for the angels a couple really
good solid defensive plays including a
relay throw
and two really good quality bats a
couple runs scored for rent today
[Applause]
yeah count that as a potentially
pleasant problem for joe madden
to have too many pieces offensively
because that's not been the story for
much of the year
[Applause]
and radhiko strikes out
one gun for farmer in the eighth
joe madden over the weekend by the way
speaking of the angels manager
just passed davey johnson
on the all-time managerial wins list
here's david fletcher now with one gun
he's been hacking at the first pitch all
night
chopper and he's gone there's two away
you know we asked joe madden because
joe's been at this for such a long time
and you know that he's matched up
with miguel cabrera a bunch in his
career and we asked him for his what's
your moment where you
i mean you either got burned by cabrera
or you remember of something on the
field and he recalled
chapter and verse roger
an episode
managing tampa bay years ago
where in a three-game series
three straight games in the seventh
inning with runners at first and second
and two gone he walked miguel cabrera to
load the bases and on each time
his reliever was able to get out of the
jam but i mean you talk about respect
wow that that
that's some respect right there three
straight nights
he walked him with runners at first and
second in the seventh inning each time
he had the courage to conde continue to
do that yeah
maybe more into left field man was that
ball scalded
credit but do forgetting they're quickly
holding upton to a single
yeah after getting an infield hit that
was a rocket down the third base line
for humpton really settled in he's done
a nice job in that lead all spot 21 runs
scored in 21 games for justin upton in
the lead off spot
ooh joke around call him
ricky upton
joe biden likes to call him
ricky upton lead off hitter
he's the ricky henderson character
[Applause]
now we need justin to start talking
about himself in the third person like
ricky henderson used to do
i tell you what ricky ricky has some
great stories
was he around the a's a lot when you
were there he was definitely around the
a's especially spring train he come down
for about two weeks and we would just
laugh and laugh and laugh he had some of
the greatest stories
baseball stories or non baseball stories
i'm talking about baseball story i'll
talk about fans just kind of constantly
wearing him out and him going to the
fans and like man give me a break you
know this kind of thing ricky his
storytelling is on point
following a strike to count to jose
iglesias
hey
excuse me foul ball
in his memory of what pitcher's trying
to get him out with he knew every single
pitch he tried to get him out with and
if he had a conversation with him at all
you know hey this is where you try to
get me out on a 2-1 pitcher just the
pitch who tried to get me when you were
head 0-2 he was he was incredibly
intelligent on the baseball field he
knew exactly what he needed to do both
at the plate in the field and definitely
on the bases our research guys are fast
gooby i'm told that he hit just 229
against you
come on dig your stick yourself
otherwise it was
i am right now but he didn't get me one
time he set me up i threw it first he
threw a first pit i threw a first pitch
fastball i think he was going to take it
and he got me and he did his ricky uh
home run try too oh ricky made that
famous
ricky oh yes
and the shirts
i was like no way swinging the first
pitch let me just get a fastball over
and he and he starts laughing at me as
he's going around i couldn't oh my god
he got me
he got me
fallen two strikes to count to jose
iglesias
a runner aboard with two gun and a
three-run game
didn't come at the slider it's two and
two
[Applause]
when the tigers bet in their half of the
night
it'll be castro cameron and grossman
they're eight nine the top of the order
hitters
jonathan scope's been their biggest bat
tonight he bet fourth and we're going
right there in a three-run game
farmer strands a runner
to the top of the ninth last chance for
the tigers trailing by three
[Music]
the tigers had won their first three
games of the 84 season when their ace
took the mound in chicago on a cold
saturday afternoon
and if there could be drama in just the
fourth game of the season jack morris
provided it i went out to the mountain
with one thing in mind to win the game
and to finish the game
swing and i missed
we got it going now jack morris has not
allowed a hit for seven innings
morris didn't need a lot of help that
day
but when he did his defense made sure he
got it kirk gibson made the best play of
the day out in the outfield in right
field to preserve a no-hitter on one
pitch to rudy
gibson going back on the track at the
wall one hands it
and now even the white sox fans are
cheering for mars once you start to get
to the sixth and seventh inning you know
everybody starts to be aware of their
surroundings and start preparing for
what might happen
[Applause]
morris no hitter was probably typical of
our 84 season you know that was showing
you in advance of what our year was
going to be like
[Music]
new to the mlb game of the week is the
youtube player of the game
fans watching tonight
on mobile devices computers you can vote
for which player you'll receive will
receive the trophy during our post game
show coming up in a bit stay tuned for
the player of the game polling options
who will be our player of the game
tonight a couple of pretty strong
candidates and we present for your vote
either shohei ohtani
or taylor ward the guy who broke it open
with the slam
vote now
tigers fans are probably watching
thinking hey wait a minute there's still
three outs left for one of our guys to
be a player of the game and you're right
we reserve the right to change the
nominees based on the result of the game
here's willy castro castro cameron and
grossman as reichsel iglesias continues
looking for a six-out save
and it ain't going to come easy because
castro has an extra base hit to lead
things off in the top of the ninth
[Applause]
point the real nice shot was staying
back on this one
right there and really when you look at
yeah with his numbers slugging versus
change ups and breaking balls much
better this one he stays back on a
fastball this allows iglesias to provide
the power for him and laces that left
field for a double
[Applause]
so now daz cameron who doubled and
scored one of the three eighth inning
runs
iglesias
single game pitch count high is 30 this
year
he's at uh what are we at 17 and
counting here and he's still three outs
away from closing this down
[Applause]
two balls are no strikes
[Applause]
we have somebody up in the pin
[Applause]
goopy you're there anybody up behind you
down there now okay
he's got one out
castro to third and your mindset is a
closer in this spot is that that run
doesn't matter at all it's the guy
coming up on deck that's the guy you
worry about
[Applause]
he's a tough hitter now mention him how
good
bobby grossman is with runners in
scoring position this is a very
difficult out for iglesias
[Applause]
just one career played appearance
between these two iglesias with his time
in cincinnati and grossman with his time
in houston and oakland
0-1.
grossman has walked struck out flight
out and singled in a run tonight
[Music]
well this a big hitter here gooby to
your previous point because jonathan
scope on deck has been hot he's hot
tonight
and if grossman gets on base
he'll bat is the tying run
yeah i'm looking to gross he looks still
comfortable even though he has two
strikes because he's been swinging the
bat
well 98 mile an hour gas
and a very difficult bet is retired on
three pitches
that's one of those pitches did you ride
a 98 above the strike zone when you have
a hitter tracking low
change in eye level just couldn't quite
bring the hands up see how he pulled off
on that when that four seam fastball
upstairs
by design at 98 that was a great pitch
because he was tracking something well
whether to change up or slider he was
going to hit it hard but that change of
eye level got him out
jonathan scope is homered and singled
takes a fastball for his strike
a bomb in a strike down
i guess it missed him and i guess he
checked his swing it's two balls in a
strike
i think that was suzuki that took time
two balls in a strike to scope
[Applause]
so very productive
patient at that worker for scope now not
chasing not being overly aggressive
trying to do damage
jonathan scopes chase percentage goes
way down when he's ahead
and he lays off that fastball and now
the tying run will have a chance to dig
in at the plate
i mean no no six out save is gonna come
easy
and now perhaps just to give iglesias a
blow matt wise comes out for a
conversation
[Applause]
jamer candelario has a couple of hits
he's also walked tonight and chris
rodriguez is up in the angels bullpen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after candelario it would be miguel
cabrera
[Music]
[Applause]
boy credit the tigers they have not gone
down easily in this game
the ward grand slam the big five run
inning by the angels
aj hinch's guys counter punch with three
in the eighth and now they've put the
tying run at the plate
with two out in the top of the ninth
one
that one gets away from suzuki
castro's able to score easily to make it
an even more interesting story
two-run game now with two out in the
ninth
[Applause]
get us over through this one in the dirt
and
suzuki didn't get the body over there to
guaca try to get it with the glove and
it gets by him overthrown
fastball
fletcher's throw is able to retire the
side and finish business tonight wow
tell you that was a tough tough play for
fletcher he's playing in that
short outfield that baseball's in the
dirt hits the grass and stayed low he
stayed with it a long throw able to
finish off the game and that was not an
easy one for the halos credit the tigers
they did they fought all the way through
to make it a close one is joe mata picks
up his 1312th career but see how that
baseball stayed down
and you know that roger as a runner
you're thinking okay i got a shot inside
slow it's different for an infielder
exactly that ball took an unnatural hop
and for fletch to stay with that ball
it's pretty impressive boy the angels
able to hang on a well-earned two-run
win in front of the home crowd nearly 40
000 fans at angel stadium
as the attendance restrictions are
lifted full capacity tonight
and what a fun one for the fans to watch
in person
our youtube game of the week post game
show starts right now
the youtube game of the week post game
show is presented by chime back with rod
jay davis and mark gouvez on matt
vasquersian in the aftermath of a
two-run win for the angels one made
possible in part in large part by taylor
ward's offensive heroics tonight his
first career grand slam part of a big
five run seventh and taylor joins us on
our post game coverage tonight hey
taylor congrats walk us through the
plate appearance in the seventh it was a
quick one because you were up there
swinging at the first pitch
yeah i was just ready to go um you know
no outs earner on third just trying to
do what i can early put up on there and
just happen to get a little too good i
mean tell us about the feeling first
career grand slam coming in front of a
packed house tonight
oh it's great uh first career granny
that's awesome
anyone got that ball i'll take it but
i mean yeah having everybody here having
it back to normal i mean it's it's what
we want so it's great so i could do it
can't tell before the game i was talking
to you about you know you had an
infielder's glove an outfielder's mom
catchers man i'm thinking all you want
to do is swing the bat look what you did
swinging the bat with the bases loaded
yeah didn't need the gloves but uh yeah
i mean it's it's special i'm super glad
i could come through there and uh
yeah super happy that we got the win hey
taylor so you mentioned something
interesting there looking for somebody
to get that ball back to you it looked
like it hit the rock pile in center
field and then took a wonky bounce i
think somebody's got it maybe the ground
screw guys have gotten it for you has
there been any reports of that ball
being located
no i i'm not sure um you know
occasionally our bullpen guy manny gets
it but uh we'll see we'll just have to
see if not it's all good just glad we
could win come out here and win in front
of this crowd we're gonna take another
look at it again the slam and i don't
know if you have a monitor but uh man
we'll do our best to try to put a gps on
this thing and get the ball for you but
i also want to ask you about batting
third tonight uh in kind of a reworked
lineup with iglesias getting today
rendon down and of course mike down talk
about you know that and and what your
comfort level is are you good anywhere
in the lineup or do you have discussions
with joe about that
[Music]
no i don't have discussions with joe um
yeah it doesn't matter where i am in the
lineup you know i'm just happy to be in
the lineup so that's all that matters to
me um
i mean i love being in that spot uh
you know i enjoy it and again like i
said it doesn't matter to me so
it's great
taylor the excitement with everyone here
at the ballpark could show hey otani on
the mound how cool was that overall for
the fans to be here to experience that
and be able to pull off the double here
tonight as well
oh it's unreal shohei is amazing i mean
obviously everybody knows uh he's a man
and it seems like every time he comes
out he just shoves and does his job so
um it's super great playing behind him
when he's on the mound and you know it's
really fun to watch him he's at the
plate
taylor i want to talk about that finish
on that home run swing man and the
balance that you showed on that that was
nice
love love when guys can just finish and
hold that pose i enjoy watching that
i appreciate it
been working hard to get to this point
so i just want to keep it going hey
taylor last question for me man is the
catcher's glove still in your bag or is
that is that
done of course it is headed out here
today um you know it's just
again like i said wherever joe wants to
put me wherever he wants to put me in
the lineup whatever position i'm ready
to go so whatever he needs whatever the
team needs i'm here for him way to go
man uh we really appreciate taking some
time with us congratulations on the slam
and the victory and uh and thanks again
for the time congrats
absolutely thank you guys taylor ward
with a big day for the ann
grand slam first career slam you can
listen to the applause he's getting
there man
yeah look at that scene water water boy
i mean having the fans back in that
career yeah yeah that's right i think
you know any first is gonna be great
whether they're fans in there or not but
i don't think taylor is ever gonna
forget this night in that moment a slam
in front of 40 000 fans
i mean he's aggressive i love what he
said you know joe could put me anywhere
i have about three gloves every day to
the ballpark as long as he pencils me in
in the batting order whether it's
seventh sixth or third like he was here
tonight for the angels in there and
doing some damage with a grand slam
so you know a funny thing happens uh
along the way to uh a shohei ohtani
start where there's another player that
kind of dominates the headlines and that
was ward with the grand slam however our
viewers have voted
and it's shohei otani that is tonight's
player of the game
gooby walk us through his night
well i mean you know he didn't use his
splitter a whole lot tonight but his
slider was really really effective for
him he goes six innings only one walk so
he's been better as far as more
consistent strikes he threw 78 pitches
49 strikes got two double plays turned
behind him he had only had one turn
behind him this entire season but he had
the ground ball worker for him today
uses fastball but i love his slider
today that's the thing about joey he's
so smart knowing he has four sometimes
five pitches to go to and he went with
his slider to get the big out today
instead of the splitter or even his cut
fastball era came down from 2.85 at the
start of the game it settles in at 2.70
as a result of his efforts tonight his
10th start i mean there's no doubt in
anybody's mind he's heading to denver as
an all-star coming up in less than a
month
should be fun had you ever seen him
pitch before tonight i have not seen not
live anyways um pitch but um it's it's
fun watching him uh from from the tv
screen so you caught him on a weird
night because as mark mentions you know
he had a career-high slider usage
tonight we didn't see the split as often
as we do generally but give me your
takeaway give me your thoughts on otani
on the mound well i mean he was he was
effective he was effectively getting
getting ahead of hitters and once you
get ahead you know obviously it's it's
hard to hit him you know once he gets
two strikes on batters you're not going
to have much success and that's what he
was able to do he's able to get ahead
and and and really put put put away the
batters you know it and i guess an
example gooby of a guy who's winning
differently a lot of sliders and the
strikeout total i i say only in air
quotes only five which is a pretty low
total for him kind of just a different
method for him a different plan tonight
yeah there was about three starts ago
where he didn't really have a great
fastball maybe not necessarily a great
splitter going he went with his cut
fastball got a lot of bouts it's amazing
how he reinvents himself whether in the
batter's box or on the mound today he
fielded his position very well on that
bun got over there quickly just a little
bit of a throw away from first base
where he would have made a play there
and then showing his dance moves at
first base feeling that ground ball to
the bag too so he did a little bit of
everything but i love what joe maddon
once told me just a few weeks ago he
goes there's something about shohei no
matter what the scenario he will adjust
and be able to go out and do whatever it
needs to be able to get a w and he did
that today the angels snapped their
three-game losing streak the three-game
winning streak of the tigers goes away
and
we'll where's that that's not anaheim
did we go to balboa island and i when
gooby and i weren't invited
it's brutal brutal
bottom of the seventh inning the angels
trailing it five to nothing
they put the rally monkey up on the
scoreboard and this place went berserk
they've had so many rallies this year do
they have another one left in them
swinging a high drive deep to right to
the wall
[Applause]
the angels are breathing and right back
into it
there's a swing a long drive deep to
right it is
[Applause]
it is a one-run game
the never say die angels giving their
fans a thrill down the stretch
senate belted left field in the gap here
comes diggins here comes anderson the
angels take the lead six to five
we are one strike away from the game
seven the two two pitch
swung on
and the anaheim angels
are still breathing
we are going to game seven incredibly
[Applause]
the angels defeat the tigers in their
first of a long four-game weekend series
seven to five the final tonight in case
you missed any of the highlights here's
how it went down
it is the 26 year old two-way wonder
shohei ohtani to make his tenth starting
assignment of the year most recently
friday in the desert grossman stays put
and it's a swing and a miss probably a
good thing they didn't send him there
scope strikes out so two runners aboard
now for the future hall of famer miguel
cabrera and a fastball just poured right
past he couldn't catch up
three fastballs strikeout a guy that's
known as one of the better fastball
hitters in baseball the angels are
hoping to have
anthony rendon back tomorrow first ball
swinging is a keel badou and that one's
into right field
but do showing that flash he's around
second on his way to third
boy this from our angle here i mean that
was as bad as textbook as you can do as
far as getting to the relay band taylor
ward a first round pick at the catcher
throws that in the red heap of him right
on the money good tag by keith wong
right on the back the throw gets him at
third base you can't play that any
better as far as hit your relay man
here's the other part of the big story
tonight rod jay it's matt manning making
his major league debut tonight because
it opens up the rest of the plate you
know the last thing you want is
hitters
and the last thing you want is his
hitters to be comfortable
through the hole
coming around to score throw gets away
from haas at the plate it's an extra 90
feet for red heapho and the angels are
the first to score tonight david
fletcher hits the hole on the right side
that scores red heapho two nothing
angels but the secondary pitches are the
ones gonna set up the fastball that's a
good idea to use it
see that's it right there wow he slipped
a 95 mile an hour heater right past
upton who was not looking fastball well
he's got a couple more years left on his
massive contract and he's 94 hits shot
oh
man that got him in the helmet it just
got away from ohtani
that's always scary that
going up up and in in
into the batter's
head and shoulder and neck area those
are scary scary moments for
batters
yeah you're right it got him in the arm
mercifully
rare is okay
[Applause]
[Music]
first and second nobody out and detroit
is turned away in the fourth one out
here in the fifth he'll face justin
upton for a third time
struck him out for a second time on a
lively 95 mile an hour heater and he's
feeling it now
and he loses otani for the second time
this is what happened when shohei got to
first base with miguel cabrera that's
that's miguel cabrera all the time
doesn't matter who it is
that's him all day there he goes again
and ward is locked up on a 95 mile an
hour heater
all that for nothing one gun for
jonathan scope who struck out twice in
the game tonight 2-1
oh man
well headed to left field upton can only
watch and that one is gone
a hangar that jonathan scope rushes to
make it a one-run game
jonathan has been on a tear late and
that's what
he does with mistakes
there's one that's bounced to the right
side ohtani picks it up
[Applause]
dance moves
i'll tell you just cannot take your eyes
off this guy
everything he does is is better
and more fun to watch than with anybody
else in the league
it's a slider
and it's five strikeouts for ohtani that
was just a great opportunity great time
to steal got this picture
[Applause]
this is awkward
walsh is involved now
[Applause]
jose iglesias is the pitch hitter a
non-starter getting a scheduled day off
his feet
he picks on the first pitch and drags it
into left field
red epo scores
fletcher is held at third and it's three
to one angels one on one off now a
two-run lead for the angels and taylor
ward with the base is loaded over three
tonight so far
ward swings and sends a drive to left
field that one's got a chance
taylor ward's first career hit with the
bases loaded
is a grand slam that has blown this one
wide open
[Applause]
well credit the tigers because they
would pardon the pun claw their way back
a run already in for detroit candelaria
would walk to load the bases that was it
for mike myers joe madden had to go back
to the bullpen and reissel iglesias was
called on to execute a
six-out save
cabrera caught looking nico goodram
would follow with an rbi single this
made it a 7-3 game
and that would bring the tying run to
the plate another run would score for
detroit
on an eric haas ground ball
seven four angels here
but then iglesias would get a kill badou
to ground out and the angels would
escape with the lead in town
seven four game top of the ninth
and the tigers keep fighting late
two out runner on iglesias would walk
scope bring the tying run to the plate
and then a wild pitch would make it
interesting
it's a 7-5 game now
and on the very next pitch david
fletcher makes the fine play and mark
kubaza pointed out this ball hit the
cutout
and that
took a skid when it hit the lip
fletcher made a good play on it to
preserve the victory for the angels
time game summary a 7-5 win for the home
side seven runs on 12 hits for the
angels
five runs on 11 hits two errors for the
tigers the angels three-game losing
streak is gone as the tigers lose
their three-game winning streak let's
send it out to alex curry
well matt we knew that it was going to
be a fun and exciting night here at the
big a with the fans back in the stands
in full force they were loud they were
wild i loved it you could tell the
players loved it they were feeding off
of it especially shohei ohtani who put
on a show tonight and proved why he is
much must watch tv now we heard mike
trout during the game even some tiger
players share that they were so excited
to watch him play tonight we even heard
miguel cabrera having a great time with
him each time he was on first base he
was playing with them he was messing
with them but something that i mentioned
during the game was how great it is to
see shohei otani show emotion this
season you can tell he's having a good
time he's in the moment he's making
great plays he's getting excited for his
teammates making incredible plays behind
him it really is a different otami that
we're seeing this season and i think
there's a there's a few reasons why
number one he's healthy he feels good
both on the mound and at the plate and
it's showing even there look
he can do it all
he's laughing about it his teammates are
laughing about it he's having a great
time this team is having a great time
but it really is just so fun to see
shohei ohtani
show his emotions show that he's having
a great time both on the map and at the
plate and i know these fans here tonight
they were in for a treat to watch ohtani
put on this performance here tonight
maddie you bet a fun night all together
for fans for the angels for the home
side tigers will try to respond tomorrow
in game two of the series and we're back
with more on the chime post game show
right after this
[Music]
he
just smokes it
[Music]
great baseball right there
[Applause]
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Applause]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
oh
welcome back to the youtube mlb post
game show presented by chime after an
angel's victory in this series opener
back with rojay davis and mark gubazon
matt vasquerjen and let's talk a little
bit about matt manning guys who made his
major league debut tonight five innings
to work allowed two earned runs on four
hits struck out three walk two about
two-thirds of what he threw tonight
gooby was a fastball but i don't think
you can look at this as anything other
than a successful major league debut for
the young
right-hander yeah guys i was really
impressed being down here to be able to
see from this angle how that baseball so
freely came out of his hand and after
that first inning where you had
obviously you're going to be a little
bit nervous the butterflies going real
good release point for him on a
consistent basis take a look at our
stack cast 3d powered by google cloud
where his pitch were 77 of them 54
fastballs slider 10 chain jumping
through seven curveball usually one of
his best pitches really is his knuckle
curveball he'll get better with that one
as he goes along but he recognized that
it today against the angels there's a
number hitters in that lineup that
really hit breaker balls and off speed
pitch as well he went with his fastball
after going through that and i thought
he threw the ball well picking up his
first career strikeout although that
baseball somehow made the stance by
michelle's regulars my bad i'm sorry
about that but i you know what i like
this stuff a lot 47 strikes this four
hits a loud three walk i mean two walks
three strikeouts that fastball is good
athleticism that comebacker in the
mountain you can tell he's a former
basketball player because he jumped up
and made a play made it look easily so i
i really think this the future for this
kid is going to be really good matt
manning has outstanding stuff and he has
a presence just like aj hints told us
before the game there's something about
him he's got a lot of confidence and he
showed it here tonight you could see it
you know raj i mean you could see it
with him first round pick big arm big
prospect and and we saw major flashes of
that tonight yes you could see also the
confidence that he had on the mound he
was out there and he was attacking
attacking hitters he was attacking
hitters in the zone especially when he
got even behind an account he was still
attacking
in his own he and obviously
um you know just to go out there and and
have an outing like that is is
definitely a plus for him you know you
you want him to take his last
um his last appearance in in the modern
leagues which was a good one and bring
it up to the major leagues and that's
that looks like what he did he was able
to bring that that that um that vibe
that um that that feeling of of being
successful um of of of executing and
what i saw was an explosive fastball
right i saw that ball exploding out of
his hands and it looked like it stayed
on that same plane so it it's it's it's
a little tougher to hit when when when a
pitcher is able to do that i'll give you
one one thing he's got to do differently
he's got to sign those autographs with a
ballpoint not a sharpie
sharpie a fade over time
uh dawson wright content creator on
youtube saying tiger's rotation is going
to be nasty in about two years dawson
you're spot on dude absolutely right
with um tarek skubal
with whom we chatted casey mize i mean
the future is very bright from a
pitching standpoint in detroit gooby
[Music]
headlines from around the major leagues
uh
this dude jacob degrom uh yeah they had
an mri on his shoulder came back clean
after he came out of his last start
after three innings giants are still
rolling what is going on there
kevin gossman is a big time cy young
candidate oakland a's have won six in
row off to their best start since 1990
and they topped the pack in the a.l west
some of your old uniforms roger and
there's a lot of them hanging up in the
in the house yeah uh oakland a's off to
a great start and the angels witnessed
that firsthand this week having been
swept in oakland yeah absolutely well
it's actually fun watching the a's
getting off to that start a lot of the
guys that that are there now were really
really young they were just coming into
the big leagues and getting an
opportunity to play and you know not
really knowing um at that time you know
how how good they were you know when
when you're a veteran you can see you
see they're talented you know these guys
are going to be good in in a couple
years from now and now to see them just
kind of just coming into their own you
have uh matt uh chat chappie and um you
have um first baseman olson i mean these
guys are coming into our own these guys
are are they they've always been good
you know and and now they're really
starting to get comfortable at this
level yeah gooby i want to go to you on
the degrom story because i know that
you're a long admirer of his talents i
mean you know we we talked about kevin
gausman there and that little rip being
pretty good this year you darvish has
had a nice year it just feels like it's
the grom sci young award to lose and
we're only in mid-june
yeah i mean he has more rbis than uh
than he's allowed runs this year on the
mount i mean he's been phenomenal he's
going that fast ball at 100 plus what
about 130 times already this year
he's amazing i mean and you know he's a
hitter you're going to get a chance to
go up there and try to make contact with
a fastball throwing that hard but yet he
has that life that goes through and up
in the strike zone the illusion is if
it's rising up in the strike zone he's
got those good secondary pitches too and
i love what freddie freeman said about
him he was hey i know you get some rbis
but we want as baseball fans seeing you
on the mound every five days you know
what the rbi's the swinging the bats are
okay stay on the mound that's what
everyone wants to see him perform
throwing the baseball our final
highlight on the uh mlb youtube game of
the week post game show has to come from
a bygone era let's take you back to
2016.
uh-oh don't go there no not not down low
look at you
three-run shot against chapman
and i was in the ballpark that night and
i was among the many that thought rajay
davis is going to be the mvp of the
world series the tribe is going to come
back and win and we asked joe madden
about that today
on our call
and your connection died in the car
i had no connection i had no service i'm
like wondering what's going on here i
want to listen to this
and what can i do so what we asked him
was have we and we asked you the same
thing like you guys had never spoken
since that dramatic moment in both of
your careers exactly
he never he never found you the next day
i mean the series happened so fast
there's bigger things to talk about than
hey nice swing against my closer
yesterday dude like he wasn't about to
do that but he did say this scooby which
i thought was fascinating
he was wondering why you didn't steal a
bag and i and and you know what i was
kind of wondering why i couldn't steal
it
that was one of those those
instances like okay you know i'm i'm
ready to go but you know i was i was i
was out was that in the 10th well that
was in the 10th right that wasn't that
was after the rain delay after the rain
delay right right and uh i just had got
a single uh rbi single got the first
base so i'm ready to go we got
mike martinez up um and you know i'm i'm
i'm ready to go but you know i i was
totally stan stand down so you know i i
uh i was i i had to listen at that time
i was a little nervous about it
it could have been different history
gooby yeah if they'd let our guy run i
know the indians would have won series
i broadcast a lot of games with roger
davis when he's on the base something
and you know what you better just hold
the ball for a long time otherwise he's
going to be at second and then he's
going to be a third base because you
were a great base dealer and you disrupt
the pitchers because you got more
fastballs for that hitter at the plate
because that was their only chance if
they got a fastball a good fastball to
be able to throw you out because you're
a really really good base dealer
well that's that's one thing that i
always
really try to focus on and just trying
to you know break the pitcher's
attention and his focus you know because
when you break his focus you know
obviously he's not going to throw you
know pitches the same he's he's he's
going to make more mistakes and if he's
focused on me trying to throw trying to
get me out of at first man don't don't
try that please don't try that
you know because you're just playing
into my game i said i want you to do
hey let's take a look at the upcoming
schedule of games on youtube
a's and uh rangers on tuesday the 22nd
and melanie newman the voice of the
baltimore orioles will be calling
play-by-play for that one coming up on
tuesday the 22nd schedule continues with
seattle and toronto the following week
and then the reds and brewers on friday
july 9th it has been a pleasure
gentlemen mark gubaza rajay davis
thanks for being with us tonight on a
global audience on youtube
the angels win the series opener
thanks for watching
i'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you